>> JACOB WENGER: I am a huge
soccer man fan, have been my
entire life.  I have found
memories of playing the game
grow willing up excluding the
time Is I got kicked in the face
it's a game I'm playing in or
not.  Over the years you could
say I have learned the p
rimitives of the game, pass,
shooting, dribbling, defending,
doing skill moves.  Each concept
have a player skill set.  In a
similar withdraw, security for
gut when you compose them
together you can form powerful
rules and protect data even for
complex applications.  And today
to speak and I will train you on
these  concepts.
If you haven't ghessed it, I
will be using the help of the
swoart R sport oi love.  I sl
been on the Firebase team over
two years now.  So you could say
on the real time database.  I'm
hoping to share the knowledge
with you today.  I know it's
early and I'm talking about
security, a traditionally boring
subject, so I thought I would
spice it up a bit and instead of
Firebase security, we will talk
about the key to Firebase
security as told with  emogi.
So
you will be seeing that over the
next  half hour.  You heard how
Firebase is more than just a
real time database.  It is a
suite of integrated products to
help you develop your app, grow
your user base, and earn money.
gap a little Brit between the
old and new world and talk to
you about security in your
Firebase apps across two
different products.
The first is the Firebase real
time database.  This is the old
reliable battle tested real time
arbitrary Jayson data such as
team schedule.  The second
product is the brand shiny new
Firebase storage.  You will use
this to store files like video
might lights from last night's
match or an audio clip of a
Spanish announcer screaming g
oal!.  I do not know how they
hold that for so long.  Thank
you, thank
you.
In order to explain Firebase
security, I first need  need to
tell
you what exactly do I mean by
security.  The way I see it is
that there are two sides to the
security coin.  On one side you
have authentication and on the
other side you have
authorization.  What exactly do
these terms mean?
Authentication is the process of
verifying users are who they
actually say they are.  So this
user is Sarah, and this user is
Billy.  Authorization on the
other hand is the process of
determining who has access to
what data.  So maybe Sarah has a
ticket to the match and is going
to be ail to get in whereas
Billy is empty handed and w
illing stuck watching the game
from the pub.
Traditionally implementing both
sides of security took a lot of
work.  You had to manage your
own servers, you had to set up
your own databases, and you will
serverside code to protect your
users.  Thankfully Firebase
makes this simple because we
have products that do this out
of the box.
On the authenticationside, we
have a product calls Firebase
authentication.  Very original,
I know.  Firebase authentication
allows you to verify users in a
bunch of different ways.  Behave
allows you to sign a unique
identifier to every user.  We
have email password age next
indication which allows you to
verify user using a combination
of email and  password then
there
is O off that uses third party
like face bike or Google to
authorize on your behalf.
Finally, there is custom
authentication.  When you need
something extra, or custom, and
or you need integrate request
wantisting off solution.  I
won't be focusing very much on
Firebase authentication during
this talk but if you are
interested in it, tomorrow at
1:
1:00 p.m. on this stage, best
practices for a great sign in
experience.  So if you want to
learn more, check that out.
What I will be focusing on
today is authorization.  The way
is we use what we call Firebase
rules for both the real time
database and for Firebase
storage.  I think the best way
to learn this stuff is to
actually go through a ton of
different examples and we are
going to start with learning the
time database rules language.
Before we can actually protect
data, we need to know what data
we are going to  pro protect.
Kicking things off we will start
with example data.
The real time database stores J
SON data.  Sear we have an
empty JSON object we can say
let's put a top level games n
ode.  This is where we will
store all of the game
information including the
schedule for the current team.
Within the games node we are
going to have a bunch of random
IDs which we call push IDs in
the real time database and these
will uniquely identify every
game in our list.
So within each game we will
have a bunch of different
content about that game.  We
will have the date of the game,
who the opponent is and whether
or not the game is open to the
public.  There will also be a
game content node.  This is data
ticketed
customers only so people who
have bought  ticket to the game
should be able to see stuff in
game content.  Lastly we will
have a tickets node and this
will be a list of users who have
tickets to the game.  The best
place to start with security is
with what the defaults are.
Additionally our default rules
looked like this.  Just like the
data you store in your real time
database, you're rules are also
a JSON object.  It has a top
level rules node, and then
within that by default we have
read true write true.  This is
the first primitive we will
learn,.read and.write, it
determines who has read access
and who has write access.  So as
I'm sure you can tell, this m
eans everyone and anyone has
access to all of your date sta
both to read it and write it.
This is pretty great for getting
started because you can go ahead
and create new Firebase database
and start writing and reading
from it right away,  but it also
malicious attacker, to steal
your data.
How would they do that?  They
can easily circumvent them by
writing a few lines of code.
This is using the Firebase 3.0
SDK.  What we are going to d
o, with those of you familiar
with the real time database, you
used to do new Firebase and pass
your database URL now, you will
all  Firebase.initialize app.
And the database oral which is
where you are going to store
data.  Once you have an instance
of an app, you can get a
database instance and then c
all.ref on that.  That will
give you a reference, a pointing
Firebase real time database.  We
won't pull data yet but we can
do that by doing a once value.
This will do a get on our data.
This will return a promise
fulfilled with the snapshot of
the data.  This is an immutable
snapshot and we can extract data
This is not great.  So as of
yesterday we have updated
default rules when you create a
Firebase real time database.  So
instead of read true write true.
We are going to see off does not
equal null for both of those.
This is the next concept, this
off variable.  This is a top
level variable populated by the
rules language itself and it
represents the authentication
state of the client making the
request.
So if I'm making a request from
a laptop that is not
authenticated with Firebase,
this auth variable will be null
and I won't be able to read or
write data.  If I'm making it
from a phone authenticated with
Facebook, the auth variable will
not be null and it will contain
UID which is a unique identifier
specific user signs in via
Facebook, they will be given the
authenticated I will be able to
read.  So this is better because
providers are enabled for your
Firebase database when you
create it.  By default no one
did read or write data and you
need to add authentication.
Let's say you want to add
anonymous oak thent case which
is common use case for many
aches.  Now, a guy who can see
the rules says I can work with
this because they are still a
bit too open.  Let's look at
code.  We will initialize the
app in the same way.  Now we
will call auth.sign in a
nonymously.  We will be
authenticated and any request we
make from this client will have
a non-null auth variable in the
rules.  We go ahead and after
that promise is fulfilled we
will get I reference to our root
of our database, we will this
time remove the data and then we
removed.  So this is kind of
terrifying.
terrifying.  And not what we
want by the time we release our
application to production.
So I know exactly what you are
thinking, you are saying this
saying this is
really easy Jacob, all you need
to do is lock this thing down.
So we can do that.  We can say
let's go ahead and say no one
can read and  no one can write
anything at all.  100 points, my
touching my data.  This is very
true, but it also kind of r
enders your app pointless.
Kind of like the face massage
emogi which I legitimately have
never had a chance to use before
beyond this obviously pointless
rules set I want to introduce an
read and write false is
equivalent to not putting those
rules at all and the default
value is false.
So this is a contrived example,
but these two rule sets are the
same.  This will come into place
allow anyone to read or write.
So let's say we will grant
public access to all of the
games node.  How can we do that?
We will go ahead and create a
games node within our rules and
say read true.  So everyone can
read all of the different games
and see the entire schedule.
This is not exactly what we want
want to have only ticketed
customers or only people who are
games we allow them to be p
ublic.  So we can go ahead and
make a semi public schedule by
instead of doing read true,
actually specifying the game ID
for every game and for the top
game, we know the public flag is
it set to true so we will put
read true, and for the other
game, we know that it's not
public, so we need to be
authenticated.
So this works, although it has
a couple of issues.  The first
is that this read true rule is
hard coded.  And the only reason
we put read true is we know the
data we started with the is
public field was set to true.
But what we want to look at is
we want to look at the is public
field itself and use that
existing data to 2KER78 our --
determine our rule.  We can go
ahead and do this by changing
both of these rules to the same
rule.  And the rule is going to
say, am I authenticated?  Or is
public field set to true?
So we start with our auth does
not equal null and then we say,
we use the data variable.  This
is a top level variable like
auth which represents the
existing data in your Firebase
real time database.  So we say
at the current location, which
is games/that long UID, is
public child stet and is its
value true?  If so, allow anyone
to read this note.
So this is getting us closer,
but we still have another
problem.  These game IZs are
randomly generated push IDs..
We won't know what they are
before our app is sent to
production so we can't hard code
to have to specify the same rule
over and over for all of the
games.  So we can go ahead and
get rid of that and replace them
with what we call wildcard
locations.
That's what this dollar
represents.  So dollar game ID
is a wildcard character kind of
like a variable that will match
all strings.  So it will match
all of those game IDs that we
previously saw.  Now, instead of
specifying this rule that we saw
earlier for every game, we only
need to specify one time.  So
this is good except for the fact
that the data we store in the
games node is actually, we want
different access levels for
different pieces of data.  For
this top field, the date, the
opponent and the is public f
lags, that should always be
publicly readable by everybody.
shouldn't be ail to look at the
date, opponent and is public
flag.
Whereas the game content we
only want ticketed customers to
see this or see it if it is
public and then the tickets n
ode, we will want to lock down
on a per-user basis where I can
go ahead and buy a ticket myself
dome person can't -- random
person can't write to  my ticket
this, let's put a read rule on
our game and then underneath
that we will say, you can only
read the game content given that
And then for tickets, we do
want to do it on a per-user
basis, but for now we will say
do you have a ticket, if so, you
eems like it would work except
it actually won't.  That's
because of what we call the
rules  cascade.  Which is a core
The rules cascade.  Essentially
says in order to read data at A
/B/C, you just need a read rule
that evaluates to true at any
level in that parent hierarchy.
So in order to read the data at
games, game ID, game content, we
actually would start at the top
and look at the games node and
say do we have a read rule here.
We don't, but we know that that
just implies that we have a read
read won't be allowed at that
level because we don't, we don't
move to the  next level and go
to
game ID.  Game ID does have a
read rule which evaluates to
read true.  The read will be
allowed.
And so we actually will
completely ignore this game
content read rule.  That's
because if we are allowing
people to read games/game ID,
then they certainly are going to
game content.  In addition this
tickets room won't be included
either.  So we need to work
around this a little bit.
The way we can do that, one
option is copying these two
rules we had previously and then
specifying read true for every
field we want to be publicly
readable.  This definitely w
orks, but it involves a bunch
of different read rules and now
every time we want to add
another public field, we are
going to have to add to our
rules.  So if we want to add a
time to let people know when the
add a rule which is time read
true.
So we can actually get around
this by restructuring our data a
opponent and is public at the
top level of the game, we can
get rid of it, add a metadata
node and throw those things in
the metadata node.  We can
refactor our rules in a similar
way, get rid of the three rules,
replace them with a single
metadata rule  which is read t
rue.
Our rules are simpler, we have
fewer of them and if  we want to
add the time node, we don't have
to add anything to the rules.
We can add it to metadata and it
The next thing we want to talk
about is this rule here.
Currently we are  allowing
people
to read the game content node if
they are authenticated at all.
In our soccer example, this
essentially would be I have a
ticket but I have a ticket to
some game, not I have a ticket
to this game.
So we actually want to lock it
down to only people who have
tickets to this game not a
ticket in general.  So in order
to do that, let's take a look at
what our tickets node look
looks l
ike.  Wore going to have it k
eyed by unique identify e
veries.  These are UIDs I was
talking about earlier.  So it's
a long, you can assume it's a
random string and we are going
to create a hash map of those,
of those UIDs.  And so we can go
and say our tickets node is
going to be keyed by UID.  So we
read and write if off.UID equals
dollar UID.
We know the auth variable has
user identification state so
currently logged in user and if
their UID is the same as the
location we are writing to,
which is the dollar UID, we will
allow them to write to the node
and read from it.  This is what
we call user based security.  So
we have locked down the  tickets
node.  The next thing is lock
down the game content need.
What we want to say is if the
tickets node has the currently
logged in use are's UID as a k
ey, then allow the read.
We can do that by using a
parent reference.  So we take
data, which, again, is the
current data at that location.
We call it parent.  Then we go
to the tickets node.  We see if
it has the currently logged in
user as a child.  So the last
thing in this example I want to
talk through is being able to
edit the schedule itself.  Here
we can add an admin's node at
the same level as our games node
in our data structure and we
will key it again by UID of all
of the admins of the app.  You
can throw a bunch of profile
information.  For here I will
put the name.
So we want to lock down that
metadata node which determines
the schedule so that only admins
can write to it.  The way we can
do that is by using this root
reference.  So we say root,
which is going to take us to the
root of our Firebase.  We go to
the admins child, and we see if
the currently logged in user is
in that note.  So that works, we
able to read it read it and the
people who should able to write
it can write it.  We need to
validate that the write is
actually correct because you
could write wrong data, you k
now, write a date that is not a
date at all, but that's not
really what we want.  So we copy
our rules from the previous
slide.  And then we say let's
add rules to date and opponent
which say the new data must be a
ere?  We are referencing the
new data that questioner about
to be written.  Whereas data
talks about data that's
currently stored before the
write, new data will be the data
opponent, it must be a
string.
This seems like it should work
but we run into problems with
the rules cascade.
So in this example, let's say
we try and write a number to
metadata/date as an
authenticated admin.  We would
first touch the top rule, which
says are you an admin and it
would say yes, I am and at that
point the date rule would be
completely ignored.
This is not what we
want.  So
we can look at it the other
direction.  Let's say we want to
write a string but we are not in
admin.  We first would go to the
top right rule, go are you an
admin, no, not an admin thoan we
says are you writing a strike?
Yes, I am writing a string and
we would allow that to happen
completely ignoring the admin
rule which is not what we want
because we want to lock down
writes to admins.  How can we
solve this?
All we need to do is change the
write rules to what we call
validate rules.  Validate rules
are different than read and
write rules and the way I like
to think about it is in order
for a write to succeed, all you
need is one write rule in that
hierarchy to be true.  So all of
together if any one is true.
Whereas with validate rule you
need all validate rules to be
true.  So validate rules are a
nded together.  So with
validation you do complex stuff.
data we are about to write must
have a date and opponent.  We
can also say more complex things
than just is it a string?  We
can use regular expressions to
verify the date has the proper
format.  We can use contains
queries, which is this is kind
of an arbitrary example, but we
can say the opponent must
contain an S in their name.  We
can say more things like is this
a bullion or is this a number?
One tricky really like is this
dollar other field.  This is
kind
of a trick that says dent
allow other nodes to be written
to the feel.  So dollar other
will match other strings that
aren't date opponent and are
public.
So these are really just a few
examples of what you can do with
actually combine them in a bunch
of ways and do complex schema
validation including i
mplementing things like c
ounters, time expiring data and
even user rate limiting.  So we
have seen a bunch of different
examples of how to actually do
security rules, but I'm going to
one thing to actually key code
on slide and another to actually
over here.  And this is the
brand new Firebase dashboard.
How many have played around with
this
thing?  A little over half
the group.  So it looks more
beautiful than the old d
ashboard.  On the left you can
see the products that are a part
of Firebase.  We will be playing
with database and that's what we
see right away.  We see the data
currently stored in our Firebase
database.  I have already
prepared some example data, and
I will go ahead and load that.
It will have the same format as
placing w so we have a bunch of
different  admins keyed by UID
and include the name of the
admin and then we have a bunch
of games that include game
content which we lock down to
ticketed customers.  We have
metadata which includes is
public field and tickets keyed
by UID.
So we can actually play with
these rules by going to the
rules simulator.  The first
thing we will do is click this
button here and that's actually
going to open up our simulator.
So by default, again, our rules
are you need to be authenticated
ay, hey, I will read from/games
even though I'm not
authenticated.
We will see that the simulated
read is denied.  The cool thing
is you can come in and see which
So we can go ahead and we can
work around this.  We can say
let's put games.read is going to
be true.  And we run this again
and we can see the rules cascade
allowed but then we will head
down to the rule on line 6 and
see that the read is going to be
allowed and because read rules
are orged together, the right
overall will be allowed.
And then if we look at just
reading from the root again, we
will see that, again, we are not
So we can go ahead and see this
a little bit more if we swap the
put our read rule at the top,
move this read rule down here
within games, and then try and
read from/games again.  We will
see the rules cascade where we
hit the read rule at the top and
second read rule because it will
be allowed and similarly when we
just read at root, it's going to
be allowed.
So let's go ahead and add the
rules that we came up with
during our slides and copy them
here.  This is exactly the full
set that we talked through, and
we have our rules for the
metadata node, for the game
content node and for the ticket
node.  So we will go ahead and
publish these rules which will
actually upload those to
Firebase servers and put them
live in your app.
And then we are going to try d
oing some writes.  The first
thing we will do is we will
write to games, and then we are
going to want to grab one of our
game IDs and so we will head
over here and grab the first
game ID.  And head back to wry.
Games/that game ID/metadata.  We
will right with just FU.  So we
click run and we see we are not
going to pass because we are not
authenticated so the auth
variable is not set.  So let's
authenticate.  Here you can see
the authenticated section where
we R we can choose providers we
can pretend to authenticate w
ith.  And we can override the U
ID we use in the a
uthentication.  For now we will
use the randomly assigned UID
and click run and see that, man,
we still failed the same rule,
even though we have an auth.UID
now, but we are not actually an
add
admin.  We head to the admin
section, we grab the admin UID
and throw it in here and now we
run and, all right, so we pass
the rule on line 8, but now we
are failing one of our validate
rules.
It says new data must have date
that.  We will change this to
have a date, which will be
tomorrow, and we are going to
intentionally have a mistake in
there where we put three
characters for the year and then
ahead and say we are going to be
playing arsenal tomorrow.
If we run that, we will see we
now pass the first validate r
ule, but that still doesn't
allow the write to happen.  We
failed this regular expression.
that 2016, click run, and now we
see all of the different rules
succeed and our overall
simulated write was allowed.
You can go to this details
section to get a ton more d
etails about why the write
allowed.  You can see the type,
where it was written to, what
data, what authentication state
was, whether or not you were an
admin and a bunch of different
data for each line that was
executed in the write.  So if we
head beaks  back to the  slides
you have
gotten a rolling tour so far of
both 9 rooms language -- the --
the rules language itself and
the actual simulator.  If we
head back to the slides., h
opefully you guys are not
feeling too over Elmed at this
point and -- overwhelmed and
realizing the breadth of
security, the options you have
available to you.
I realize that a lot of you I
have gone through a bunch of
stuff already and you may be
feeling a bit stressed or you
may be feeling more scared or
you may even possibly be feeling
like this and be completely lost
and we realize that.  Security
is not easy.  There is no
getting around that.  Firebase
has also taken a different
approach to security than many
of you are familiar with.  So in
rules work consistently -- were
one of the hardest thicks for
new  Firebase developers to
figure out.
We heard that feedback and we
are actually playing around with
creating what we called rules
compilers.  So first game a
compiler calls blaze.  Which
introduced stuff like types, and
then came Bolt which built on
the work of when blaze and
included generic types.  It
included a cleaner syntax to
write less code and it also
included match pads to make
rules easier to read and write.
But there was still a problem.
rules, languages and compilers
were all database specific.  Now
real time database.  It's now an
integrated suite f products.
That's kind of where the next
product comes in.  Firebase
storage.  We needed a rules
language for Firebase storage
and we felt the existing rules
language left too much to be
desired
desired so we went back to the
drawing board and built a new
rules language from the ground
up, one that borrowed heavily
from the real time database
rules the things we liked and is
different learnings we got from
our Blaise and bolt compilers.
>> . So it's early days for
the Firebase storage.  There is
lots of stuff we still have
planned and that is still going
to be coming out but I quantity
to give you a walk through of
the existing features and show
you how you can use it to
protect your files in Firebase
storage.  Before we actually
look at data, before we look at
rules, we need to look at data
we are protecting.  The real
time database stores data like
this.  We have a users node, we
have it cued by UID and we have
profile information.  This is J
SON data.  Firebase storage on
the other hand is going to be
protecting data like this.  This
you would have on your local
file system.  Instead of a u
ser's node, you  you would have
a
user's directory and you would
have a directory for each user
and for each user you would have
a bunch of different immannings,
audio, movies and text files.
This is the stuff we will want
to protect.  So what do the
rules actually look like.  The
syntax will be different from
the real time database rules,
but the concepts are very much
the same.  So we start with the
default storage rules, and the
default rules say we first are
going to specify which service
we are using to write rules so
we are going to say we are using
the storage, the F
irebase.storage service.
Within that we need to specify
what bucket.  This is our Google
reading and writing files to.
Then we will use match 35Ds.
The way to interpret the syntax
is the curly braces are
equivalent to the dollar
wildcard locations in the real
time database rules.  So what we
are saying here is it we are
going to match all pads, a
wildcard all  strings and the
equals dollar dollar says allow
it to be many levels deep.  If
you all had all paths with all
equals with no dollar dollar it
will be only one level deep.
And
Within that we will say allow
read and write.  We have a more
compact syntax because we are
able to do read and write on the
same line.  If request.age is
not null, allow read and write
to happen so the rooms are
equivalent to the real time
rules for the dbts there are
differences in the actual
conditional to auth has moved
from a top level variable into a
will contain the information
about the request be willing
made, the read or write.
So let's look at a few more
examples.  Maybe we don't want
to actually do read, write, only
if you want to make the stuff
public.  We can do that by a
llowing read write with no
conditional.  More compact
syntax than the database rules.
Similarly, to do private, we can
go ahead and just add in
conditional which says if false
which will always allow, which
will always evaluate to false.
So this would not allow anyone
to read anything.  Finally we
can do user-based security.  So
instead of doing the all paths
match, we are going to do a
match path which looks like t
his.
We are going to say go to the
users' directory and then do
match any string which will be
our UID, the unique identifier
for the stewser and then match
all files.  This time we are not
using equal star star so we are
not  doing multi-level match
paddeds and we will say you are
allowed to read and write if you
user.  So we say request.auth.U
ID equals UID.
That second UID comes from the
match pad itself.  So let's head
talk about storing game
highlights.  Like we had in the
real time database, we will have
a top level games directory
instead of a games node.  We
will again key that directory by
the game ID, so the data between
the two is actually looking
similar, the structure.
And then within each game, we
will have a highlight reel, we
will have a recording of the
audio.  And we will have a bunch
fan images will be keyed by the
unique identifier of those fans,
bunch of different images.  So
we want to go ahead and write
rules to protect this data.  The
first thing we will do is write
a top level match path which
says/games slash game ID.  So
this is the kind of thing we did
are doing it much more c
ompactly.  We will nest match
pads like we were able to nest
rules in the database rules and
we will say if in game/game ID
we have a highlighted movie,
let's allow everyone to read it
and let's allow you to write to
it if you are authenticated as
an admin.  Here we are using a
new concept, this is using our
custom authentication.  That
auth variable that specifies UID
in the rules language, you can
make any variable with net auth
variable.  You can say auth.is
mad min.
admin.  And then we store a
bunch of custom attributes that
we want to write.  In this case
we will store whether or not the
Next we need to do rules for
the recording, audio file, and
those rules are going to be
identical to the  highlights r
eel.  Finally, we need to
protect our user's data to
within fan images UID file name,
we will allow all of those to be
read.  It's a public view, but
we will only allow you to write
it if you are that logged in
user.  So we can go ahead and
clean up some of the rules and
make these more compact.  The
first thing we will do is notice
that the rules for highlight
reel and the recording are
identical.
Let's get rid of one, slightly
change our match pad to say just
update our write rule from which
currently just checks if we are
admin to also check that the
file name itself is either
highlights.move or recording.M
P3.  So we have
gotten rid of a bunch of lines.
extract this read rule from
these two rules because we know
that everything is publicly r
eadable.  So if we pull that
out, we go ahead and squish
those two down and we create a
match path for all paths as many
levels deep as we want and just
put in allow read.  We have now
taken what was initially six
rules and made it down to three
which is much easier to read and
easier to understand, less to
keep in your head.
do with files is validate that
they are of the correct type and
that.  So the validation for the
storage language is quite
different from what we have in
the
rules language.  We start
with our rule which says you
need to be logged in user, and
then we will add a rule which
says the size of the resource we
are about to write has to be
less than 5 mega bytes.  We can
do things like check content
type and  verify the content
type
of the resource we are writing
is an image.  Even more so we
can actually determine which
kind of rights we are  going to
allow.  We can disable deletes
by doing a request resource does
not equal null.  If you think
about this.  This is saying if I
election that is null which m
eans I'm obliterating which is
there, then I won't able to
do
that.  One thing I'm excited
about is functions.  This is
something that people love from
the Blaise and bolt compilers.
Let's go ahead and take a subset
slide and turn them into
functions.  First we will start
with is this the current user.
We will create a function called
and we will just return that
same rule set verifying that the
the UID the function takes.  If
that is true, we can go ahead
and replace this rule here with
a much shorter rule which is
just is current user and pass
the
UID.  Pass is the size of
the number of mega bytes we want
the rule down here with a call
to less than N mega bytes 5.
Finally we can take the rule
that checks whether or not the
file is an image, create a
function called is image which
returns the same exact rule and
replace the call down here with
is image.  So we have taken what
was a pretty long and hard to
read write rule and turned into
something clear and easy to
understand even if you don't
write the rules yourself, you
could read and understand who is
type of files will be written.
It's short enough you can fit it
This is a huge improvement over
the existing rules language, and
I think you guys will find that
it will clean up a lot of your
code.  That is the knew Firebase
store rules language.  It's
composed with a dozen or so
primitived which you can compose
together to form clesm file
access rules and validation.  It
the database rules language i
tself, but also all of the new
improvements that we got from
things like Blaise and bolt.
And it is better situated for
the new multiproduct world that
Firebase now occupies.
At this point, I think
congratulations are in order.
You just made it through my
9:00 a.m. talk on security.  You
now know the tools you have at
your exposal to protect your
Firebase data in both the real
time database and in in storage.
primitives and put them into an
existing app or if you are new
to Firebase a brand new app and
make sure you are protecting
your data.  If you are
interested in learning more, you
documentation, head on over to
Firebase.Google.com.
We have documentation from all
of the Inc. did products.  You
also can find out about all of
the other parts of Firebase, all
announced yesterday by heading
to our features page and lastly,
has made Firebase successful so
far and it's something we
continue to try and strive and
do our best at and that's not g
oing to be exchanging any time
soon.  So please head over to
surf port page, join our
community, join our Google
groups, join our stack overflow
community and be a part of the
conversation.  Let us know what
features you want, whether it's
with the rules language, whether
it's with the actual database
rules or storage or any other
product.  We definitely value
your feedback and a lot of what
we released yesterday is based
on feedback from customers like
you.  Also brand new You Tube
channel with a bunch of really
cool intro videos for all of the
new features and you can find us
on Firebase on Twitter for all
of the up-to-date news.  There
is still a lot of cool stuff
happening at IO.  We have two
full days left.  Half of the
office hours are over but you
should check out the one that's
at 5:00 p.m. std or one of the
ones tomorrow.  If you are
interested in seeing Firebase
sessions there are double digit
talks left about Firebase.  Two
that you may be interested in,
one would be zero to app develop
with Firebase tomorrow at
10:00 a.m. on the main
amphitheater.  This is a really
cool talk where they will be
building an Android and iOS and
a web app all from scratch that
includes storage, database rules
and authentication, all in 45
minutes.  So it's going to be
exciting.  Whether or not they
are able to do it, so you should
The other talk is the one I
mentioned about Firebase
authentication.  That one is on
this stage tomorrow at 1:00 p.m.
come join us right at the sand
box right next door, and we can
take a look at one of your
existing apps, talk through
rules in your app or talk about
the new features.
Thank you, everybody, for
coming this morning and learning
security.  My name is  Jacob
Wenger you it find more at
underscore J Wenger.  Thank you
very much, peace out!  Do not
forgot to protect your Firebase
data!
(Applause).
Services Provided By:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
800-825-5234
www.captionfirst.com
This text is being provided in
a rough draft format.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART) is provided
in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may
not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
* * *
Coming.  I'm Todd.  I work on
fire bass cloud message ing.  I
focus on performance, specifical
ly reducing battery consumption,
improving liability and
reducing lanty.  With me on
stage is Ciaran
>> Today we're here to discuss
some of the details of cloud
message ing performance, clulg
including how we measure
it, some typical latency numbers
we see, some of the factors
that can affect that performance
and finally a few of the cool
projects we've been working on
lately to help make the service
even more      more robust
especially in the face of
unreliable networks.
We've had kind of a busy morning
.  I haven't had a chance to
talk to you.  I saw yesterday
that firebase ed cloud
message ing is the new Google
Cloud message        messaging.
Does that mean this whole
presentation is out of date?
>> No. I'm glad you asked. So
as you all heard yesterday, we
launched a combined suite of
services called firebase.
Firebase cloud message ing is
the Google Cloud message ing
under that suite.  The data that
we're going to talk about today
applies to both services.
Before we get started, I'd like
to review a couple basics real
quick so we're on the same page.
So first let's look at how adown
stream message flows from your
serve ers to the devices.
So when it flows from your serve
ers, the first hop is the
thefire base ed cloud message
ing front end.  From there it's
time stamped and persisted to
storage        storage.  If the
device is connected, it's sent
immediately to the back end
server where it is then forward
ed to the device.
So let's take
another closer look from back
end to the device.  It's not a
simple arrow      arrow.  The
first hop is that it leaves the
firebase ed cloud message ing
back end and goes through the
Internet towards your wireless
network or your carrier's
infrastructure.  Within that
point there's going to be a
network address trans
translation device, NAT for
short.  That allows us to deal
with the shortness of IPV4
space      space.  This is a
carrier provide feature or
wireless network router provided
feature.
And from there -- oh, okay.
From there it travels to the
device.
One of the key aspects of this
network address translation
device that keeps track of
connections, and let's look more
closely at how that works.
So the connection list is a list
of connections and the external
IPN ports along with a timeout.
When the timeout expires for
the connection being inactive,
the connection's removed and no
more communication can happen
over in that connection.  So the
devices must reestablish the
connection.
If that NAT device is really
busy, we can run out of space
and we have to evict the least
recently used enter       entry
before it times out.
Most NAT devices are well
behaved in that they'll send a T
TCP reset when they remove an
entry from the table and that
will let devices know to
reconnect.  Some devices don't
send a TCP reset.  That leaves
the connection closed but the
devices are unaware.  We call
that a silent
close.  In this scenario the
device must figure a way to
figure out it's broken and
reestablish it
one solution for this is to send
heart beats from the connection
from the device to our serve
ers.  We do this to keep the
connections active so they don't
time out and detect more ready
ily when the connections fail.
Another an I wanted to review
real quick was lanty pert tiles.
As you all know 50 percentile
lanty
and 50 percent of users
experience more latency than
this metric.
There's also the 80 percent
latency where we have a long
tail distribution such as look
looking at the performance of
carrier wire identify
Wifi networks where
the performance of individual
carry      carriers could differ
significantly.
In situations where we control
more of the infrastructure, such
as within our own FCMN
infrastructure we can look at 95
percentile latency, which is 19
out of 20 users experience ing
less latency than that.
So enough review.  Let's start
with some of the stats.
We'll start by looking at
latency first.  This is the same
diagram that you've seen before
.  We're going to look at in
this next slide latency from the
FCM path.  So as the message
flows through the FCM serve ers
for both mobile and Wifi.  So 50
percentile latency is a small
64 milliseconds.  Ninety-five
percentile latency is 161
milliseconds.  We chose 95 here
because we control the
infrastructure.  We're able to
provide tighter latency bounds.
If we're careful we can estimate
the latency.  If we're
from the the point the
message enters the FCM
infrastructure to the point
delivered to the device.  To do
this we'll use Google hangouts
data and the traveling back from
the device to estimate the one-
one-way latency.
So 50 percentile latency from
the front end of FCM to the
client is 160 millisecond, which
is pretty low.  Eighty
percentile latency is 348
milliseconds.  We chose 80
percentile here because Wilus
and mobile networks tend to have
a lot of variance and we felt
80 percentile latency was
represent
representative of well behaved
network's performance.
Before I hand off, the data that
we've talked about now is for
connected           connected
devices.  Connect
Connectivity is an important
factor and Ciaran is going talk
about that.
>> Right.
So to give the audience some
context, when the team started
looking at these numbers
numbers, we obviously high fived
or selves, gave ourselves a pat
on the back, et cetera.  These
are pretty good numbers.  Then
we took another look and
realized like Todd just said
that these are only for devices
that already have an active
connection with the FCM serve
ers.  But there's an entire
category of devices that don't
have an active connection, and
so then the next logical
question we asked ourselves was
why?  Why don't these devices
have an active connection?  And
is there anything that we can do
to make sure that connection
stays open longer and is there
more often?
So we didn't really know the
answer to that question.  So we
did what we usually do when
we're face ed with a question we
don't know, which is we looked
at the data.  More specifically
we looked at the connection
close events that we were seeing
and we roughly categorize ed
them into one of two buckets.
And the first bucket is user
initiate ed connection close
events.  These are actions that
the user has taken that has
influence ed their connectivity
in some way.  So some typical
examples we see here are if the
user is worried about their
battery or they're not going to
see a charge er for a while,
they might turn off background
data.  Another example is if the
user is going someplace that
has poor or limited network
connectivity.  So that might be
the park, mountains, my parents'
house, hi Dad.  Another example
that we see is if the user has
turned off data by enable ing
enabling airplane mode.
They can do this for legal
reasons, like if they're actual
ly on airplane.  They could also
do it for financial reasons or
just because they want the noise
s to stop.
That's an entire category of
user events that can affect
somebody's connectivity.
There's a limit to what we can
do about those.  Yonder, there's
an entire category of external
factors that can affect connect
connectivity.
Now, the     , you may note this
category of external factors is
technically pretty close to
infinity, right?  Like there's a
whole bunch of things that can
stop a connection between your
client and the FCM serve ers.
But that's not really a useful
paradigm for us.  Instead, we
decide ed to subdivide it into
two sections.  The first is NAT
device issues.  So as Todd
pointed out, NAT means network
address translation.  That's a
device that sits between the FCM
client, typically an Android
device, and a server and doles
out IPV4 and maintains an
internal mapping.  Typically the
issues we see from that devices
are capacity or timeout issues
there's also another section
here which is random failures of
the.  He's these are evejts
that            events that can
happen anywhere, including power
surgeries and
surgeries.  There are some steps
we can take but in general
we're pretty limited in what we
can do here.  We decide ed to
focus specifically on network
address translation issues and
see what changes we could make
to make the experience better
for more users.
But first we wanted to see how
often people were actually
affected by NAT issues.  So we
started to look at the sort of
connection close events that
we're seeing out in the wild for
real mobile operators.  One of
the operators that we looked at
had 98.6 percent of their
connection close events being
explicit.  That is, not sile
lebt           silent.
Another operator we looked at
had 99.4 percent of their
connection close events being
explicit.  These are great stats
and we're really happy to see
these because it means that most
users, their connections are
staying open or if they're
actually being closed, they're
being closed explicitly.  So
both parties know the connection
has been closed and they can
work to reestablish a new one,
which means that your connect
connectivity is very high
and you're very likely to get
messages very quickly.
On the other hand, not all
operators are performing the
performing at the
same level.
Here's an example of a small
poor performing operator we saw
that had almost 40 percent of
their connection choices being
silent.  That's a huge
difference from the other two
operators that we saw.  We
wanted to kind of dig into what
was make ing this happen and
what we could do about it.  But
first it may help to go over
what exactly a silent connection
is and why it's so harmful for
us.
So here's an example of an
explicit close or what we call a
polite disconnect.  In this
scenario the device on the left
already has an active connection
to the FCM serve ers.  When a
message is required to be
delivered to the device, FCM
sends the message down, travels
through the network
infrastructure, the NAT device,
and arrives at the phone in a
timely manner.
Then the NAT device decides to
close the connection but sends
out an explicit TCP reset or FIN
packet to both parties.  Now
both parties know that
connection has been closed.
After a short duration, the
Android device attempts to
reestablish that connection.  It
does so.  And there's a new
connection that is used to
transfer data between the
Android device and the FCM serve
servers.  Then later, when
the     serve      servers need
to send a new connection, it
does so on the new connection
just like before and the message
is delivered promptly.
This is a great scenario because
again the Android device
realizes the
Here's an example of one.
Again, in this scenario the
phone already has an active
connection with the FC   FCM
serve ers.  When a message is
delivered to the device it
travels through the network
infrastructure just like before
and arrives at the device.  Then
when the router or NAT device
decides to close the connection,
it does so silently.  It
doesn't send an explicit packet
to either party.  Now neither
party knows that connection has
been closed.  Later, when FCM
wants to send a notification
down to the phone, it tries to
write to that connection, and
only then does it realize the
connection has been closed and
is unusable.  A short time later
the phone will attempt to send
a heart beat back up to FCM and
will attempt to do so on the old
, now dead connection.  When it
does that, then it will realize
that the connection has been
closed.  It will reestablish a
new connection, and FCM will
send      send any messages cued
in the meantime back down to
the phone.
The key take away here is that
this scenario causes a period of
dissection that can range
go up to a couple minutes until
the phone sends a new heart
beat     beat.  This isn't a
great experience for our users
because they could be silently
disconnected with no awareness.
If they receive an urgent
message, it may not get to them
for many minutes.  Obviously
this isn't a great opportunity
opportunity -- or
this is a great opportunity for
us to make some changes and see
what we can do to fix this.
So this is kind of a one-
one-weird trick sort of thing.
Here's the same poor performing
operator.  You've already seen
this data.  Before almost 40
percent of the connection close
events were silent.  After make
ing this small adjustment,
almost over 90 percent of the
connection closed events were
explicit.  That's a huge
reduction in the number of
silent closes that we were
seeing.  So how do we do this?
How do we make this happen?  The
answer is we reduce the heart
beat interval to below what we
thought their NAT timeout
interval was.  What that means
is that when a NAT device
typically closes a connection
due to timeout issues, it's
because it think so no data is
going to be passed on that
connection anymore.  An FCM
connection, on the other hand,
is always active.  We're always
expecting to receive data on
that.  That's how you receive
your messages so quickly.
So the trick here was to make
sure we were sending packets
frequently enough that the NAT
device realized that the
connection was still open and
that it shouldn't close it.
So here's that same data in a
different form.  As you can see,
for the first three-quarters of
the graph, the silent closes
over time harbor pretty steadily
between 1.5 million and just
over 2 million.  On the other
hand, when we initiate ed the
heart beat interval -- or when
we adjusted the heart beat
interval, that blue dotted line
you see, you see the number of
silent closes dropped dramatic
cally.  In fact, they dropped 88
percent down to just around
250,000.  That's a huge, huge
improvement, and we're very
happy we got to make that.
Now, this approach of take
taking the whole team and look
looking at mobile operator
data and coming up with a plan
and implementing that plan is
great for mobile operators,
especially large er ones where
the amount of impact that we can
have is dramatic for just that
small amount of work.  On the
other hand, that approach
doesn't really scale well with
Wifi networks.  It's not like I
can go in and record each
network and whether or not it's
a good quality one.  So we had
to come up with a different
solution, and Todd, I know you
have a lot of practice here.
Can you give us an example of
what we did to make that better?
>> Yeah.
Wifi adaptive heart beat was a
really excite ing project for me
to work on.  We started out
with a constant heart beat
interval of 15 minutes, and it
was great for most operators --
or for most Wifi networks.  But
there were a few that would be
disconnected because they had
shorter NAT timeouts than that
or more active devices.  A
simple solution could be to just
reduce the static heart beat to
four minutes, but we might
consume a little bit more
battery as a result.  What we
really wanted was something to
develop an algorithm that would
balance battery consumption with
connectivity.  We brainstormed
for a bit and came up with
candidates.  We took those
candidate algorithms and
simulate ed them against mottled
NAT devices.  Here's an
example.  The modeled device
varies its timeout in the yellow
line.  The red line shows the
heart beats as they adjust in
interval to match that and as to
Wifi adapt
adaptive heart beat.
This simulation here shows the
device was connected over 97
percent of the time.  In
comparison if this same
simulation was run with a static
heart beat of 15 memberships,
the device would only have been
connected 66 percent of the
time     time.  After we refined
refined our algorithm
and came up with what we thought
was a good solution, we took it
to the lab.  There we had four
nexus six devices.  We divide ed
them into two groups, control
group and experiment group.  The
control group kept the 15
minute static heart beat and the
experiment group got our new
Wifi adaptive heart beat
algorithm.  We connected them to
monsoon power meter so we could
measure the current power
consumption of all devices and a
Wifi network that we controlled
.  This allowed us to emulate
the various NAT behaviors we had
experience ed.
We also took a T sweep to make
sure it was operating as
expected.
From this lab experiment we came
up with some interesting
numbers.  First we could compare
the cost of doing a heart beat
versus the cost of doing a
reconnect.  We found that a
heart beat saved 36 percent
better.  Or sorry, a heart beat
consumed 36 percent let's
\lest\Less\let's battery than a
reconnect.
Scenario.
In addition if we look at a ten
minute NAT timeout device,
that's one we've talked about
before, in the experiment group
it would simply have 29-minute
heart beats.  In the control
group it would have a 15 minute
heart       heart beat followed
bay reconnect.  The experiment
group would achieve the 97
percent we   we's sympathy
lately ied and control group
only 67 group.  By increasing
the heart beat interval in
certain situations we're actual
ly able to save battery in
addition to improving connect
ivity.
We started rolling this feature
out and along the way we collect
ed data.  I'd love to share with
you some of the data we got
when we got to the 50 percent of
production users.
First, we saw 34 percent fewer
silent closes, and more TT   TTO
messages delivered.  If you
remember the GCM spec, time to
live messages are messages that
are delivered immediately if the
device is online.  Otherwise
they're discarded because they
aren't stored to be delivered
later.  They're time delivered
zero.  By delivering more of
those messages that shows we're
connected more of the time.
In addition, we improve battery
for 54 percent of users.
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa. We
improved battery for 54 percent
of users?  That's huge.
>> Yeah, 54 percent.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Wow.
>> And there's a small caveat to
that.  For a very small portion
of users, users only connected
connected 33 percent
of the time or less, we did
spend a little bit of battery.
.3 percent more battery consumed
for an \idle\idol device.  For
that small subset of users
improved three times.  I feel
like the battery numbers paid
out.  We improved connectivity
for 72 percent of users.
So as a result this feature is
live.  Everybody's phone should
have it.  And we're continuing
to think about how to improve it
further.
In addition to looking at our
own data, we also felt it was
important to look at data from
services that depend on us.  I'd
like to look at Google hang
hangouts 99 percentile latency
data.  The blue line represents
Wifi and mobile users combined.
So it's both sets of users in
one line.  And the Wifi line is
red.  It's just the Wifi users
.  What we can see here is that
at the 50 percent rollout point,
the niernt percentile latency
for Wifi users dropped.
When we got to a hundred percent
rollout, the users continued to
drop but also 99 percentile
users dropped.  That means we've
changed what problem is causing
the 99 percentile latency for
Wifi plus mobile users.  In the
end, the remaining latency for
the blue line was caused by 3G
mobile networks, when which we
focused on later.  That's a talk
for another time.  If you look
just at the Wifi line, we
reduced the 99 percentile
latency for hang     hangouts 55
percent.
So we've gone through and looked
at how GCM performs and some
interesting projects we really
enjoyed working on.  I want to
take a brief second to talk
about what can we learn about
the users of GCM from the data
that we have.  So we're going to
look at user influence ed
\dissection\disconnection
events       events.  So events
where the users decide
decided to be disconnected for a
sustained period of time.
We're going to look at events
where the user's been disconnect
ed for 30 minutes or more where
they have made the decision not
to be reconnected.
This is a heat map that I'm
going to talk about.  One thing
I wanted to point out before I
started that though was most
messages are delivered in well
under 30 minutes.  We're only
talking about the long tail here
here.  We're only talking
about messages delivered longer
than 30 minutes.  Or to devices
that have been offline for more
than 30 minutes.  This heat map
is color code ed.  Red means a
higher percentage of messages
are delivered to devices that
have been offline and green
represents a lower percentage of
messages.  We will post on the
spaces app the full set of data
for this grade so you can check
it out online.
So, for example, 4 percent of
Indian users are seeing their
messages delivered to devices
that have been offline between
two and four hours.  In the U.S.
that's only .8 percent.  As you
can see this varies from
country to country significantly
.  Let's take another look at
this data in a slightly
different representation.  This
is a cumulative graph.  You can
see 15 percent of users in India
-- or 15 percent of messages in
India are delivered to devices
that have been offline two hours
or more.  That means that if
you're developing an app for the
world, you need to take into
account the device connectivity
may not be a iewbt qus thing.
You have to make the app work
where connectivity may go away.
One other dataset I thought we
could pull is to look at day of
the week.  This is the global
data.  It's not any particular
country, but you can clearly see
that Saturday and Sunday are
days in which the users are less
likely to be available on their
devices.  Maybe they work on
the weekdays or maybe they have
phone free Saturday Sundays.
Karen, what are some things we
can do
Ciaran, what are
some things we can do where
connect        connectivity is
not prevalent.
>> I'm glad you asked that
question and totally surprised
by it.  No, I'm joke ing. just
released a new open source
library.  It's called the
firebase job dispatch
dispatcher.  This is a library
for schedule ing jobs     jobs,
discrete units of work on
Android and coming soon IOS that
let you set constraints and
triggers for these jobs.  You
can say something like I'd like
to do this download but only
when the user has an unmetered
Wifi network.  Or I'd like to
run this task every week but
only while the device is charge
charging.  This helps make
sure that your app remains a
good app citizen on both IOS and
Android and ultimately it means
that you're respecting your
user by make ing sure you're
only using the bandwidth when
you absolutely need to and
you're waiting for the most
opportune time to initiate
download or maintenance tasks
you need.
This is available right now and
you can check out those links
there.  The IOS version is
absolutely coming soon.
We also have a Codelab for you
called removing againy ies on
background services.  That's
available at the link there.
We encourage you to check it out
.  In there we go over a sample
app and talk about removing
dependency ies on background
services and converting to this
new job centric world.
This is a great way to make sure
your app is more battery
efficient and works even better
on newer versions of Android and
IOS.
So this has been us, we've been
talking about GCM performance.
We'd love to hear your comments
and feedback.  Please leave us a
note in the spaces app and I
guess we have some time for Q&A
right now.
>> Yeah, we have time for
questions if you want and then
go ahead.  Find a mic, please.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I guess they're allowed to
clap.
>> Hi. I am from Verizon
Wireless.
I have a question.  So the
presentation so far you have
shown is mainly the improvement
on like Wifi network, like the
NAT, right?  But on the cellular
network, your heart beat is to
be 28 minutes, right?  So did
you change that or it still
remains the same?
>> So I guess you'd probably be
a better --
>> So what we do is we look at
the performance of carry iers
and we try to say well how this
carrier doing.  One of the
things we may do is if that
carrier is performing poorly we
may try a couple heart beats and
see how they do and reach out
to the carrier and contact them.
In some cases we can even
extend the heart beat interval
to 60 minutes, which is really
awesome        awesome.
>> So you base ically take a
look on the carrier and it's not
fixed number; it's dinely
dynamically changed.
>> The number is based on the
operator based on the
experiences and performances
performances we see
on that operator.  Operators
that have short NAT timeouts
timeouts we'll adjust
that heart beat interval to
match that.  If they have a long
timeout, like Todd was saying
some have almost 60 minute time
outs, we'll extend that heart
beat as much as possible because
we know how much the battery
savings matter to our users.
>> This is something we try to
work with carry iers as well.
So when we make changes like
this we'll reach out to the
carry iers and coordinate with
them as best we can.
>> So is GCM becomes firebase ed
something, you guys change the
name?  What is the new name?
>> So GCM which was Google Cloud
message ing is now firebase ed
message ing, or FCM.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Hi. I notice you guys update
the end point from -- so the
boast GCM, FCM end points are
available.  In order to take
advantage of the work you guys
are doing, do we need to switch
the end point from GCM to FCM?
>> Our infrastructure
improvements are going to affect
both APIs.
>> You shouldn't have to make
any changes to your app.
Everyone gets this built in.
>> Okay. Thank you.
I mean my server by my app.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Thank you all for your
time.  We're going to hang out
over by the fire bass booth if
you have individual questions
after we get untangled from
these speakers.  Have a good day
day.
[ APPLAUSE ]
The Firebase plug-in which I
guess is more correctly called
the play services plug-in for
Android, you might be curious
what happens with that plug-in.
Well, I'll tell you a little
bit about what happens.  Three
things.  One, it will read a
configuration from your Google
services.  So Firebase is just
like Play services was where you
go to a console, you get a J
sun file, drop it into your app.
This contains configuration
your app will use in order to
operate correctly p the      .
It will inject Maven
dependencies.  This is actually
groovy code, not java code.
You'll notice the lack of a
semicolon and single quotes
around some of the strings.
What we're doing here is the
plug-in will reach into your
project, look into its
dependencies collection and add
a compiled dependency on
Firebase core.  Now, this
Firebase core module is kind of
interesting because it contains
no code.  Now, why would we add
a dependency on something that
contains no code, !  That seems
kind of weird, until you look
inside the maven palm file for
this.  Palm file is just sort of
metadata about how a dependency
looks.
You'll look in the highlighted
section here you can see that
the Firebase core module depends
on Firebase analytics.  So when
you apply the Google services
plug-in to your Firebase app,
you will get analytics for free.
It's kind of important to note
, this is how important we think
that analytics is for your app.
You get it always.  It's a
crucial part of Firebase
applications, and you'll see
that throughout this conference
how Firebase analytics actually
enhances the cape ability ies of
the other components that you
use in why you are app.
The third thing that the plug-in
will do is inject some
resources.  You can see in this
bit of code we're reaching into
your project, into the Android
configuration, and for each of
the variance that you're
building, what we'll do is find
a unique location for that
variant that's your file output
directory.  Then we'll create a
task.  This task, what it does
is it will generate resources
when it's called.  On that
variant we can register a
resource generating task, pass
that task that will actually do
the work and feed it the output
directly.
What happens is this is an API
within the gradeall plug
plug-in when it's called you can
say if this plug-in wants to
generate some resources this is
an output directory that the
rest of the build will use to
look for those resources.  It
drops fully formed valid Android
resource files, XML files that
will be merge ed into the build.
So what all this task is doing
is it's reading out of those JS
ON file all of those values and
keys and configuration and
storing them as resources.
That's how your app actually
gets ahold of all the different
things it needs to operate
properly.
So if you're developing with
Firebase, you'll likely come
across this new task API.  This
is how a Play service is doing
concurrence y within the app.
This is like the API pretty much
all products will be using
going forward.
This is created just for
Firebase APIs.  However, this
could be applied to any sort of
play services API in the future.
Now, for Firebase specifically
if you're using remote config,
authentication, or file storage,
you will run across this task
API.  It's an important thing to
know.
So the general form of the A
sync API, we'll call it Firebase
ed thing and say you call a
method on that do stuff.  This
do stuff method, if it wants to
do things asynchronous
asynchronously, it will
return immediately and generate
a task object.  This task object
is parameterize ed by some
result, whatever it wants to
generate.  We have a task that
wants to return some result.  On
that task it's a representation
of background work.  On that
task you can register listeners.
You could have a success
listener and then there's a call
back in there that will receive
the result type when it's been
generate ed.  You can register a
failure listener which then
receives an exception of
whatever happened that caused
the task to fail.  So that right
there is all you actually need
to handle these things correctly
.
Now, there's a third version
where you can register an on
complete listener.  What this
does is bundles both success and
failure up into a single call
back.  If you choose to use a
noncomplete listener, what you
do is you get a task and you can
ask that task, did you complete
successfully?  If you did, give
me your result.  If you did not
complete, then give me the
exception.  You can choose.  You
can register either success or
failure separate or independent
ly or do a completion listener
and handle both in the same
callback.
So there's four ways to get task
results.  I've showed you the
general format, but there's four
different ways, and you should
know each one of them.
First of all, there's a call
back on the main thread.  This
is what I showed you in the
previous slide.  You can add a
success failure completion
listener, give it a listen
listener, and this listener
will be invoked on the main
thread.
Now, there's a different format
and you should know this one.
This is actually more important
than the last one, where you can
get a callback scoped to an
activity.  What it means to be
scoped to an activity is this
listener that you register will
not get execute ed if the
activity goes through its on
stop.  If an activity is being
stopped the listener will not
execute.  This is important
because if you register a listen
er without unregistering it when
the activity dies you can have
an activity leak.  That's
terrible.  Long running task
that exceed or go beyond the
life cycle of an activity can
cause a leak.  This causes out
of memory problems and they're
actually very difficult to
diagnose.  If you're calling
this API within an activity, use
the second format, the format
where it accepts an activity
object and you only register or
only have that listener for that
one activity.
If you want to receive your
result on another thread, not on
the main thread, if you want to
handle in the background and
say you wanted to do more block
ing work in that, now, if you've
never dealt with an executor
before, it's base ically a JAVA
or    identify's thread
.  Make an executive decision
how do you deploy this to
another thread.  Could be a
single or pull of threads or a
growing and shrinking pull of
threads.  This API doesn't care.
The executor cares where the
thread goes.  You just hand it
an executor that makes that
decision.
>> The last way is you can block
the current thread if you want
to wait for the result end line.
I say right away don't do this
on the main thread.  Don't
block the main thread.  We can't
say that enough.  Don't do that
in your Android applications.
It can lead to a fairly bad user
experience.  But if you do want
to block some other thread,
there's a utility method on task
s called await.  You can give it
the tasks that you want to wait
for.  It will block and then
the result will come out of that
.  Now, if you're not willing to
wait indefinitely, you can feed
it a timeout.  That timeout
will sort of time box the amount
of time you're willing to wait
and return with an ex execution.
Now, you will have to capture
both an execution or an
interrupted
interrupted, so you'll have to
handle that case here.
So let's say how do you do a
sequence of work?  This can be
common in some Android apps
where you have task one which
leads to task two, so on, so
forth.  You have to do them in
order.  There's a special way to
express this in the task API
using continue with or using
continue with task.  There's a
subtle difference between the
two.  So if you're using
continue with, you will have to
create a continuation object.
What a continuation object does
is it says I know how to --
there's some result type for
input and some result type for
output.  And within my method
when it's called then     then,
it receives the task that's
generating the impact type
type.  You can see inside the
method.  We're calling task get
result.  That returns the input
type.  We can do some
transformation, do whatever we
need to do and generate an
output type in response.  To
make use of that you just call
on the origin task, call it task
continue it, feed it the
continuation and that feeds you
yet another task, which is
parametertize ed by the output
type.
If using continuous task, it's
very similar but slight
slightly different in that
continue with task generalates a
task.  It doesn't generate the
result type directly.  It
generalates a task that is
responsible for generating the
output type.  The form of the
execution is the same task dot
continue with task
.  You can then wait on to get
these results.
Now, it begs the question -- I'm
on the wrong slide.  Okay.
So the up-shot of all this task
chaining business is you have a
sort of sin tactic sugar for
execute ing a series of tasks.
If you're like me with and
worked with data promising
frameworks like spark, you know
you have a series of steps you
have to execute.  Say for
example you have a query and
that's going to generate a
result set, then you want to
filter, maybe do some mapping,
one data point to another, sort
those results and group them by
type, you can express that very
suck      succinctly like this.
This is how you do serialize
ed    ized chain of execution.
So if you want to do parallel
task execution, and I would say
this is actually more common
than serial task execution, if
you want to do it in parallel,
and this is very common if you
say want to kickoff, I don't
know, an authentication and a
query and do a database read and
you want those all to happen at
the same time but you only want
to progress to the next step
when all of those are complete.
So you only want to wait as
long as the longest one of those
tasks.  So to run things in
parallel, you can use tasks dot
win all.  Tasks again is utility
class.  Win all is utility
method that says I'll take each
one of the tasks that you want
to wait on and I'll generate
from that a final task.  This is
asynchronous.  You'll get a
task in response asynchronously
programtize ed.  It doesn't
generate anything.  But gives
you a target to listen to to
know when the lists are complete
.  You add a success listener.
Inside there u you can reach
into all the other tests
inflight and get the results.
It's worth note ing that if any
one of these tasks fail, the
entire thing will fail.  So
you'll need to check for that as
well.  Same thing with serial
task execution.  If any one of
your tasks in the serial chain
fails, the whole thing will fail
.  In fact, that exception will
get propagate ed on from task to
task until the final result
will receive the original
exception that caused the
failure.
So the easy iest way to et crew
your own                  create
your own task is to create a
callable.  It's a java construct
.  Very similar to run
runnable.  Runnable takes
nothing as input and generalates
nothing as output.  Callable
takes nothing as input and
generalates some programmerrize
ed as output.  We're create ing
a callable, programmertize ed
and simply puts out that print
type.  All you do is tasks.call
and feed it that call.
Immediately you'll get a task
object that you can wait on to
get that result.
Now, it's important to know that
tasks.call will schedule your
work to run on the main thread.
If you're doing some blocking
work in your callable you
probably don't want that.
Probably want to schedule it on
another thread.  There's a
format that takes an executor.
Create an executor
executor, schedule your work on
that, your task on that, and
then you can use that task in
serial or parallel tasks along
with the Firebase ed tasks.
Now, if you have your own thread
ing           threading
framework, I know there's a
bunch and everyone has their own
favorite asynchronous framework
, you don't have to abandon that
to use tasks and you don't have
to wedge tasks into that other
format.  There is a way to do
some interoperability.  A bunch
of code on this and I'll try to
unpack it
the intermethod here the class
here is called task completion
source.  What a task completion
source does is provides kind of
an empty task for other threads
to feed their results into.  So
when you have a task completion
source, you can get a task out
of it and register a success
listener.  That success listener
would again be programmer
programmertize ed by the
type you're expecting
In this example I'm going tofire
up           to fire up a new
thread.  This is just for
illustration.  What you can do
is in that other thread,
whatever it's doing, if it's
going to generate some result
and you need to feed that result
into a task, you can just call
source.set result.  What that
does is the task that's in that
result will be fully complete ed
or resolved.  That's how you
can have things in your other
asynchronous framework work with
the task framework.
So that's all great.  Now I'd
like to move onto some specific
product details.  I'll tell you
a little bit about Firebase
crash reporting.  Crash report
ing is special to me because I
worked on this.  I'm actually
the developer advocate for crash
reporting and test lab.  So I
have sort of a special place for
me with crash reporting.  You
might ask the question how do
you actually detect a crash?
That seems like a strange thing.
How do you do it?  So I'm sure
you all know this dialogue.  If
you're an Android developer you
have seen this dialogue.  If
you haven't, I'm willing to bet
you've never written a line of
Android code or you're a really
darn good developer.  And actual
ly I think this dialogue is
actually kind of funny.  It's
saying something rather
unfortunate happened and I'm
asked to be okay with it   it.
I don't think this is okay.
This is not okay.  So the button
should actually say not okay.
I really think it should say not
okay.  But in this case I'm
being asked to say it's okay.
When you push okay then the
process finally dies.
The way to handle this case is
using something called an
unC.O.D. exception handler.
This is a regular java
construct.  There this is
interface under java laying
thread       thread.  You can
register one of these.  This
will get notified if there's an
exception that pops off the call
-- runtime a no pointer
exception that made its way back
to the top of the call stack.
If you want to know if that
happened use an on call handler.
The interface for that is
pretty simpler.  Here I'm
create ing an anonymous
exception handler.  I'm going to
receive the thread that actual
ly generate ed that and the
throwable that made it outside
the call stack.
And then what I can do is to
register this for all threads
within my JVM or art or whatever
you want to call it   it, you
can call it exception handler, a
great verbose java name, pass
it that handler.  What happens
is any time for any thread if
it's going to crash with an
exception, you'll get called
before the process finally dies.
Now, actually, I advanced a
little too soon.  So if you read
your exception happened letter
that does nothing.  Like in the
previous side there was no
implementation there.  If you
register that it will actually
keep your app from crash
crashing.  It will continue to
run.  This which is probably not
what you want, because if a
runtime exception gets thrown,
that will actually -- that's a
bad thing for your app.  It
really should die.  Things could
be in a bad state.  You don't
want to continue.  What you
really want to do is call
through to the prior exception
handler.  So this is the best
practice.  This is kind of the
understood practice for
exception handlers.  The first
thing you do, you get the prior
default exception handler.  Then
you create your own and call
through to the prior one when
you're done.  This let's bunch
of components all create a
different sort of like chain of
-- not chain of responsibilities
, but a chain of reaction so you
can register a bunch of default
exception handlers
handers.  Each one will run in
turn until the original default
Android handler which is
responsible for putting up the
crash dialogue will finally run.
So you've probably seen this as
well.  This is an A and R or
application not responding.
This happens when you run
something on the main thread
that takes more than five skdz.
More often than that, some
network access or file access
that took too long.  Or some
sort of algorithm that got out
of control.  This is a bad user
experience.  It's asking me to
be okay with that.  I'm not
really okay with it and I
probably don't want to wait, but
this is not generate ed from an
uncaught exception handler,
this is Android kicking in and
saying look, your main thread is
out of order.  The user needs
to be able to decide do I want
to keep waiting for this.
Now, it's worth note ing that
inside your default uncaught
exception handler, if you block
too long, and Android, you can
still ANR the app.  Your
uncaught exception handler still
have to follow the general
rules of Android development
where you don't block it.  It's
kind of a bad idea.  If you do
block for more than five seconds
and the user chooses to term
Nate the app by saying, okay,
you'll lose that crash.  The
Android will kill your app.  In
your uncaught exception handler,
you need to be quick, let get
that crash and let the user move
on.
So all that aside, now, hold
that all in your mind for a
moment and say now let's talk
about how crash reporting actual
ly works.  At some point we need
to register this uncaught
exception hand      handler.
Crash reporting needs to do
this.  We use a content provider
for this.  That seems weird
weird.  Why would you use a
content provider to register
crash reporting?  Isn't a
content provider supposed to
provide content?  You would say
yeah, of course, but there's
some interesting properties
about content providers that
make this interesting.  It's
worthwhile to look at how an
Android process actually starts
up.  There's procedure that
every Android app goes through.
The first thing that happens
when an Android process starts
up is every content provide that
you declare in your manifest
goes to its on create in order
of priority.  If there's a
priority definition there it
will go in that order.  Now,
it's also worth note ing that
this happens in your main
process only.  If you have a
multi process app, and most of
you probably do not, but if you
have a multi process app, , the
contour providers will not be
created off the main process.
The second thing that happens is
your application sub class will
be created.  If you've defined
an application sub class which I
think something like a third of
all Android apps do this, that
will be initialize ed, go
through its on create after all
the content providers.
Then once that happened, the
third thing that happens is
whatever component that needs to
be invoked will be invoked.
Usually it's an app launch.  So
an activity will come into play.
Or a service could have been
started.  Or a broadcast receive
receiver.  Whatever the
invoke component it will not be
create ed and run until content
providers and applications all
in it.
It's worth note ing here content
provider is the early iest hook
into the Android process.  So
that's why we initialize crash
reporting there.  If we initial
ize crash reporting in a content
provider, that means we will
happen before application and
before everything else.  So
that's one benefit.
The other benefit to using a
content provider is content
providers participate in Android
manifest merger.  An Android,
you know that if you have
library projects and all of
those things from all of those
manifests all get combined into
a single manifest for your app,
so if we define in our crash
reporting library, a content
provider that automatically gets
pulled into your app and that
automatically causes
initialization.  This is great
because you don't have to write
a line of code to initialize.
All you do is depend on the
library and manifest merger will
bring our content provider in,
do the initialsation and it's
super easy for you.  Now, the
reason -- you could use
application, but applications
applications don't
participate in Android manifest
merger.  The only way you can
define an application object is
you and your manifest.  Library
projects cannot contribute to
applications, they can't hook
into on create, that's why we're
using content provider.
Now, the Firebase uncaught
exception handler does a number
of things.  The first thing is
it collects a lot of information
about the device.  This is one
when we go off and find the
device type and measure memory
and serialize the exception and
what we're going to do is dump
that all into a proto buff and
send that to a crash service.
Now, crash service is an Android
service.  The way we built it,
at least for this launch, is to
run in another process.  So the
crash services that do
persistence of the crash will
write it to disk and do the
transmission all happens in
another process.  Now, this is a
clever idea, right?  If you
remember back before you can say
, you know, the idea of causing
an ANR within your crash handler
is a bad idea.  What we wanted
to do is get all that data as
fast as possible and ship it off
to another process.  Let that
do the blocking, the writing to
disk, let that do the write ing
to network and let the main app
process crash gracefully and let
the user move on and do what
they want.  This also let's us
do persistent retry.  This other
process can keep retrialing and
sending that crash so we can
get it as fast as possible.
Now, there's a little problem
with this scheme.  I don't know
if you can see it right
awireless network.  We didn't
see it until late in the
development cycle.  I'll say a
little bit more about that, but
here's a situation we have
have.  We have a main app
process.  It goes through its
content provider, application,
and invoke components.  Now we
have this background process
that's handling the crash.  It
goes through its application and
the crash service gets invoked.
The problem here is that if
your application object is
writing to some shared resource
to a database or a file, there's
a potential for erase conflict
here.  So most app developers
don't actually depend -- or
expect that their application
object would be run twice.  The
normal expectation is that it's
run once in a single process.
Because we're running crash
reporting in another process,
that means we have a second
application object, just like
the first and it's doing the
same thing as the first.  If
your application object is
writing to a database you could
actually run into a locking
problem.  We actually didn't
detect this.  The people who
detected this were our early
access partners.  We had a
couple partners who had some
strange errors and it turned out
this was the problem.  This is
one of the reasons why we're
launching crash reporting for
Android as beta because of this.
Now, it should be told that
crash reporting is -- it's
production ready.  We want you
to use it.  We really hope you
use T. we think it's a great
tool.  But you should know if
your application object is doing
any of this writing to a
database or a file, crash report
ing may cause problems four.
This is something we're hoping
to resolve.
There's another problem with
this plan of using a background
task is there's a movement
within Google to encourage apps
to eliminate background
invisible word.  Define what
invisible work is.  Invisible
work is something your app is
doing without a UA displaying.
If you have no activity that's
started in the foreground.  That
would be visible work.  If you
have a service that has a
notification in the curtain,
that's visible work.  So if you
don't have either one of those
situations, that's invisible
work.  And at Google we're
trying to encourage developers
to cut back on the amount of
invisible work because that can
cause battery drain or 81 known
like data usage.  For crash
report       reporting this
actually is -- we're doing
invisible work so we need to cut
down on that.
I was expecting to have a URL to
a blog post where we talked a
little bit about that.
Unfortunately it's not available
.  I'll have that on Monday.  I
think the plan is to publish
this on Monday.  If you join the
spaces for this talk, I can get
you that URL.  I think it will
be posted on our medium blog.
So if you want to read more
about that, follow up with that.
So in the next version of crash
reporting, we will actually not
have a background process.
We're working on eliminate ing
that.  The up-sides of course
we'll work more widely so we
don't have to worry about apps
with application objects that
aren't compatible.  It will be
more compliant to development
where we'll be cut     cutting
back on this invisible work.
The downside is there is an
increased chance of latency.
With the old we could get that
passage sent vary vie quickly.
If we're competing with the idea
that the app may die before we
can get the crash out of the --
into our serve ers and into the
app, it's just a risk that we
just can't get at immediately.
Also this gives us a sort of
constraint of being able to
retry less frequently.  So that
said, there's trade-offs.  We're
going for the no background
process version.
Okay.  So that's crash reporting
.  I'll say a little bit about
how things work on -- oh, didn't
advance.  Firebase analytics,
okay.  Another interesting thing
, you might be wondering how
does Firebase analytics track
user behavior?  Now, if you
recall earlier, we put analytics
in every Firebase app.  This is
a very important component.
What it does, one of the things
it does, is it tracks the usage
for your app.  This is great.
You do nothing.  You write zero
lines of code and you get track
ing.  You might be wondering,
how does analytics do that if
you're not write ing code?  How
does it
reach into my app and know how
the user is using it?  So the
question that we're trying to
ask is how do we determine when
the app is in the foreground and
when the app is in the
background?  How do you track
the time spent in the app and
how do they navigate activities?
This is user      iewferl for
determine ing how long a session
is or how frequently a user is
using your app.
The way we do that is using
something called activity life
cycle callbacks.  It's an API in
Android.  Available since ice
cream sandwich and beyond.  API
level 14.  If you create one of
these and register it with your
app, you can receive call backed
for every activity in your app.
A universal listener for all
activity.  All activities
clearly have to go through their
create, start, resume, and so
either to.  You can listen to
every single one of those.  This
is how Firebase analytics
determines how users are using
your app.
So for this interface we have
created pause ed stop, resume.
You can listen to all these but
there's two in particular that
are determined in how a user is
using your app.  That is on
start and on stop.  Here's a bit
of code.  It's kind of a little
bit pseudo Cody, but this is
something you could do in your
own app if you want to track
something similar.  I'll walk
you through these lines.  The
first thing we want to do is
count the number of activities
that have been started.  We also
want to count the moment at
which the user first enters the
app.  That's userrented time
time.  Now, when we listen to
on activity started, what we can
say is if there are no
activities started, none started
equals
zero, we can record the current
time.  That's the time that the
user launched the app or first
entered it from say the task
switcher.  Then what we do is
increment the number of started
started activities.
Then as an activity is sphopped
stopped, we'll
turnaround, decrement the number
of started activities and say
if the number of started
activities is zero, meaning
there's no activities visible
right now, record the time that
they left the app, do a little
math and say this is how long
the user was in the app.  Now,
this is pretty handy, right?
This is a fairly bulletproof way
of knowing when the user was
looking at your app and when
they were not, because as long
as you have an activity started
you can be certain that you were
on the screen.  When your
activity is stopped you can be
certain that you were invisible.
This is how we track that.
So what's next after here?  I've
given a bulge of information.
bunch of
information.  If you're an IOS
developer there's another talk
in this room from an IOS
perspective.  If you want to
know anything about Firebase
there's links here.  If you want
to join the spa I say and ask
questions and interact with each
other, and I had that link to
the blog post, that will be here
as well.  It looks like we have
some amount of time left.  I'll
take some questions if anyone
would like it and thank you for
being here.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I don't think I quite
understood what the relationship
between the task API and
Firebase is.  Like can I use the
new task API and not use
Firebase or is it something
that's --
>> Yeah. So the question is can
you use this new task API
without using Firebase, and the
answer to that is yes.  Task API
is just a lightweight
collection of classes.  If you
pull in Firebase as a dependency
, you will get the task API for
free and you're not obligate ed
to use anything in Firebase.  So
yeah.
>> So what's the relation
between task API and Igerra API.
It's also observe able
observable type,
right?  So why having both now?
>> Right. So the question is
what is the relationship between
the task API and Agera.  For
those of you who don't know,
it's a library Google released
that is similar to frameworks
like RX java
>
>>
>> Test test
test test test test test test
test.
>>
>> May 19,
FB19.
Google Libraries for iOS
Developers
>>
>> May 19, 2016.
FB19.
Firebase for iOS Developers
>> Well, I guess the music
stopped, so that's my cue to
start.  Hi, everybody!  I hope
the line wasn't too long.  This
is Firebase for iOS developers,
I have an awful lot of content
to go through and not a lot of
time so I will get started and
talk really fast.  Sort of like
micro machines guy if you
remember him.  So as you may
have heard, Firebase is a suite
of integrated products divined
to help you develop your app,
grow user base and earn money
and more specifically.  We are
there to help you on iOS.  I
know we are at Google I/O and I
know you will hear about instant
apps and all of that stuff
which does sound cool, but when
it comes to  developer tools,
particularly mobile developer
tools and particularly Firebase
we take cross platform s
eriously.  We know a mobile
library is probably not helpful
to you unless it's available on
all of the platforms you are
developing for and for most of
you, doing development in m
obile, that generally means
Android and iOS.  Imhappy that
this whole cool new platform is
built under the Firebase brand
because I think people know that
Firebase is serious about
supporting iOS and will continue
to in the
future.
>> Fun fact, if I give this talk
in Spanish it looks like I'm
excited about the idea of an
operating system.  That's my one
internationalization joke for
the event.  Thank you.
Out of the features we have
available on Firebase these are
the ones available on iOS.  So
you will notice the only thing
we had to dim out was the test
lab which is specifically being
called test lab for Android for
that purpose.  It didn't fit
nicely in the slide.  Everything
you can't do in Firebase, you
can do on Android and iOS.
So this is kind of supposed to
be a technical deep dive which I
think is weird given that some
of the features are brand new to
you and you haven't had a
chance to play with them so this
talk will be more about
interesting quirks that I
discovered which I started
experimenting and p laying
around with the Firebase
platform and building my own app
which as fed lal law mandates
any time you create a new law
with a library it has to be a t
o-do app.
I don't know all of the answers
to everything, this is like this
is a neat quirk and I thought I
would give a presentation on
it.  Legits talk about the setup
process.  Generally Firebase
encourages you to use CocoaPods.
We are we are using CocoaPods
as the generally recommended
withdraw to install stuff.
Probably a lot of you know it.
It's a dependency manager that
vastly simplifies the process of
adding libraries to your app.
If you don't know anything about
CocoaPods, we do have a
fantastic video.  I'm having
trouble with the clicker.
That you can check out with an
incredibly handsome cast.  I'll
give you a moment if you want to
take a picture of the URL, go
ahead and if not, I will post it
in the Google space afterward.
One important note about cocoa
pods is you should generally
only pod install what you need.
Not everyone knows this, I
didn't know this at first, but
the thing about CocoaPods is a
dding a pod actually increases
the size of the app whether you
include that code or not.  So if
you have the choice between
installing a massive Uber pod
that has 40 features or i
nstalling a little sub speck of
that pod that contains the three
features you are interested in,
go for the sub speck.
We have structured our  pods to
encourage that behavior.  You
will notice in the documentation
for all of the CocoaPods we ask
you to install they are the
individual sub specs that are
part of Firebase.  You have
Firebase core which give yous
Analytics.  If you do try and
pod Firebase in the hopes that
you are going to install this
giant massive everything, that's
not going to work.  We just map
that directly to Firebase/core.
have to pod install every
explicit feature that you are
interested in adding.  If you
don't know about podtry, who
doesn't know about pod try.
There is one or two people or
maybe everyone is afraid to
raise their hand.  If you don't
know, it's a great way to try
out any library that CocoaPods
has available.  It basically
goes out and searches the
repository for a demo are or
sample app
that it downloads to a temporary
directory on the computer and
runs it.
You can check out the library in
action in Xcode, play around
with the code, see what happens
when you Tweet things without
having to be like, gee, I wonder
what this does and you have to
find the documentation and
sample file and download it and
do the work manually.  So we
have made sure that all of our
Firebase samples work with pod
try so give it a try.
CocoaPods released version 1.0,
congratulations to the team if
you are watching on  watching
online.  From an end user
perspective not a lot has
changed for you with version 1.
0.  Hopefully there are very few
break annuals with your pod
files unless you are d oing
something fancy.  The point of
the release is it's a forward
looking release where the team
is preparing for the future and
wants to make sure everything
can scale and is production
ready.  We are excited to be a
part of that.
But, granted, wherever I give
this presentation there is one
developer in every crowd that is
not happy with the idea of
CocoaPods.  There they are.  All
right!  Don't worry, grumpy c
ats,  we love you to.  You can
download the libraries without
CocoaPods.  What you are going
to do is download this giant zip
file that is going to contain
all of the frameworks available
and there is a step by step
guidena says for every feature
if you want Firebase messaging
you need to install A, B, C, D,
and Analytics,
, E and F.  So it takes a few
manual steps but you can still
do it.  So don't w orry, cocoa
pod haters, we still like you.
Show of hands if anyone was
secretly hoping we would support
carthage instead?  Good to
know.  Just gaging the interest
in the room.  I'm not making
promises about future anything.
We are almost all on modules
now which is generally nicer
when you are importing things
and importing is simple.  You
can import Firebase and this
will import the headers for any
of the pods you have installed.
There is a lot of has include
magic going on underneath the
hood that makes sure this works
which I know kind of sounds like
the opposite of my hey only pod
install what you need advice
that I gave you three slides a
go.
Here you are not going to
increase the size of your app if
you import  import Firebase and
import all of the Firebase
features you have installed.
Maybe there will be a slight
increase in compilation time but
I think it should be
negligible.  And it makes
development very easy.  You sort
of have import Firebase and any
feature you want to try should
work without Xcode giving you an
error.  We have Bitcode support
now.  So you can used Firebase
for your watching TV apps.  I'm
sorry this took so long.  We
have a style guide n ow, an API
review for all of our developer
libraries that are published as
part of the Firebase platform so
you should start to see
consistent class names across
Firebase which is good.  Not all
of them are there yet.  You
know who you are.  But most of
our features look consistent.
So almost all of our classes
begin with FIR and for anything
that uses a single continue you
will call it in the same way.
So the idea is once you got used
to using a couple of features
in Firebase you should be able
to guess how you would be using
some of the other features as
well.
So let's talk briefly about what
does happen when you create a
project in Firebase because you
are going to go to the Firebase
console and you are going to say
create a project and you will
wait a while and it will do
magic for you.  Then you a
attach your iOS app and it will
give you a key list file you
will download and drag into the
Xcode project.
After you have done that, you
are then going to call this one
magic call for app.configure
which will set up everything
within Firebase for you no
matter what feature you have for
you.  This configs it for you.
So what's going on?  When you
pre yate a fryer base in a
console it will create auth
clients and pin up an interest
of Firebase database to use and
Firebase storage bucket.
Whether you plan on using them
or not, they are available on
the back end to use and for each
thing it sets up, there is a
constant available.  It will be
the address of the database or
your auth client ID or Cloud
messenger, sender ID all gets
put in the P list file so when
you drag it into your app and
call for app.configure, it will
configure client libraries it
sees installed in your app and
it will do that by dragging in
all of the  constants that you
have put into the P list file.
There is no more copying pasting
various IDs from the corn sole
into combrur app..  You
shouldn't have to do any of that
which is nice.  Let's talk
about this individual feature.
I will start with Firebase
remote config.  This is a way
for you to change the look and
feel of your app from the Cloud.
When you release your app and
you realize, oh, no, I have text
that's wrong or level 51 too
hard or animation is taking way
too long if you have fired value
to use remote config you can
update from the Cloud.  So you
within the Cloud you will say
this is actually the value I
want for my button text and your
Apple download the new values
and it should be available in a
matter of minutes instead of
having to go through let's
release new build and get it
approved and published and have
everybody download the new
version.  This happens not quite
instantaneously but pretty darn
quick.
Generally speaking how remote
config works on iOS you will set
up default values.  And then
you are going to you will fetch
values from Firebase remote
config.  These get  down loaded
and they get place in cached
holding pattern on the device.
They don't get used until you
call activate fetch.  When you
call activate fetch these values
get installed on top of d
efaults.  So when you want to
retrieve the value for the
individual settings you have got
remote config will give you the
version downloaded or the
default values you have s
upplied.  And I think the
important thing to take away
from this is you don't have to
supply new values for e
verything.
What we would encourage you to
do is basically use remote
config for any value that you
have in your app, any kind of
magic number, any constant, any
text string, all of that stuff,
everything you have got and all
of that, app contents.Swift file
we have around.  This should be
set up to use remote config.
Then when you want to change one
or two you are only supplying
the deltas, only the stuff
that's changed  from remote
config.  And you have f
lexibility to change values in
the future without having to
supplies thousands of values
every time
you want to fetch stuff remote
config.
That's generally the way we
recommend you use it.  In case
you are wondering what's up with
that activate fetch call, why
not apply these values right
away, generally speaking is
maybe you don't want your app
changing mid run.  If you are
using remote config and using
values to change the layout of
your buttons or change the text
of your buttons it can be
awkward if that happens right
when the user is in the middle
of using the app.  You don't
know when the fetch call will be
complete and so we give that
power to you as the developer.
There are a couple of strategies
for how you can make use of t
his.  One is go ahead and
activate the values as soon as
they are downloaded.  Maybe you
don't care if the val so changed
in the middle of your app.
Another option is put up a l
oading screen, block until l
oad.  You will call fetch with
completion handler in your l
oading screen.  Once the fetch
is complete, you will call
activate fetch and compel the
loading screen to go away and
put up your view controller and
start your app.  Maybe you add a
time out in case things go w
rong.  So this has the advantage
of you are going to get the
latest fresh values any time
your user starts your app but
has the disadvantage of you now
have a loading screen that you
have to look at.
Maybe that's okay if you have
set up work happening in
parallel, but maybe you want
your app to start faster.  So
that's why I like this other
method which seems
counterintuitive at first but is
neat, you call activate fetch
as soon as your app starts up or
whatever enters the foreground.
This will take previously
downloaded values and apply them
on top of defaults.  Then you
will call fetch with completion
handler and you will not
actually care about what happens
234 the completion handler.
What you have done is you have
values downloaded from the Cloud
sitting on your device ready to
be applied the next time the
user starts the app.  Obviously
this has advantage of being able
to start right away, but it
does have the disadvantage of
you might be supplying slighting
older values.  You could try a
hybrid approach where you are
allowed to see when this last
remote config batch of data was
downloaded and you can see is it
older than three days.  Maybe
that's too old for my app so I
will put up a loading screen and
fetch the new values, but if
it's more recent than three d
ays, that's fine.  Side
discussion about localized text,
every time I talk to people can
you use remote config for text,
people are like, yes, that
sounds great, but I know I'm not
supposed to we have all of
these best practices on the
device for using the R.thing on
Android.  You want me to throw
out the best praik is and use
remote config.  The actioner is
you can't have the -- answer is
you can't have the best of both
words..  NS localized striping
will provide the proper striping
for the device the user is u
sing.  It will fall back to a
default language if you don't
have the language available.
You can take the localized
string value and pass into
remote config as defaults.  What
ends up happening is for
English  users you will have
English text and for French
users you will have defaults
that contain French text.  When
you realize that one of the
translations is not quite right
and it's off, you can fix it in
remote config.
You have the ability to create
conditions, and these basically
are your way of telling remote
config please supply values to
people who meet this condition.
Sometimes it's a random subset
of the audience, but often it
could be things like people
whose device language happens to
be French.  You might create a
condition for French speakers
and within remote config you
would supply a new value for
that condition.  You would say
my French speaker, this is the
value I will download.  For all
other users the default value is
no value.  This tells remote
configure go ahead and use
whatever default is supplied on
the device.  So I don't need to
supply text for all of the other
12 languages that maybe I'm
supporting in my app.  So this
will end up just changing the
stored text only on devices
where language is French.
So I'm still using NS localized
string and following these best
practices.  So that's pretty
good.  At least I think so.  In
summary, you can use remote
config to adjust localized text.
Don't use it to dynamically
localize all of your text in the
Cloud.  In theory you could do
that and maybe it's a fun hack
but don't do it because you are
downloading an entire language
pack from the Cloud every time
and that's not cool.  You get a
disappointed looking emoji for
that.
And you can use emogis in your
remote config  strings.  I can't
guarantee its bullet proof.
Let's move to Analytics.  I
might need to talk faster.  This
is the backbone of what a lot
of Firebase is about.  There is
not a lot to say on the client
side here.  You are basically,
the A PI surface is small.  You
are logging events possibly with
parameters and setting user
properties and that's about it.
So probably the most
interesting thing to note is
that if you want to turn on
debug mode for Firebase
Analytics, it's actually an
argument you pass i n.  So you
have to go in and edit your
schemes and put this in.  I
don't know why, but that's what
you have to do.
And an important note about
testing.  Analytics data is not
being sent all of the time.
Sort of as the way to keep, be
respectful of your user's
battery life and that, we are
not constantly streaming down
Analytics data.  That wouldn't
be cool.  So instead we send
down Analytics data either if
it's in an hour or when your app
goes into the background.  When
you are testing this in Xcode,
you will try firing off
Analytics events and then you
will hit stop and you will say
how come none of my Analytics
data is making it.  Is something
wrong?  The issue is if you hit
stop, your app quits before you
it has a chance to send
Analytics data.  So if you test
Analytics do command shift H and
hit the home screen on the
device and that will give
Analytics time to send down to
the servers.
I will talk about audiences.
These are basically  groups that
you can define out of things
you are recording in Firebase
Analytics.  This is people who
have reached level 30 in my game
or women in Canada between the
ages of 35 and 45 who have
visited my store but have not
purchased anything yet.  They
can be as broad or narrow as you
like.  As people use the app
Firebase Analytics will
subscribe them to these a
udiences.  One other condition
you can add for remote config is
does somebody belong in this
audience?  You can change the
look and feel of the app for
people who have reached level 30
in your game and sort of do all
of that without having to touch
the code on your client which
is kind of neat.
It's used for notifications and
I will talk about that
later.  One important note
about audiences is they are  not
retroactive.  People will
create audiences and go and look
in Firebase Analytics ant the
first question is why are they
empty?  You didn't do anything
wrong.  The reason this is
happening is in order for us to
give you  Analytics service that
is free and scales to thousands
of apps, we have to distribute
some of the work onto the
clients themselves.  So it's
actually the client that is
going to be determining whether
it belongs to a particular
audience or not.
So as people use your app, they
will get subscribed to these
audiences by the client as they
are using them.  If you think
you are going to be using the
audience for something a few d
ays or weeks ahead of time,
create audiences so they have a
chance to fill up and propagate
as you go.  Let's move onto
Firebase crash reporting which I
believe is
still in beta.  Not a lot to
say here, you add in the
library, and then crashes get
reported to Firebase.
Probably most interesting part
here is you are going to add
this script into the build
phases which uploads the
symbols file.  I think this is
standard if you have used other
crash reporting tools but this
deon fuse  indicate indicates
your stack trace.  So instead of
something that looks like this,
where you are like maybe the
problem is with method 474,525,
I should figure out what that i
s, you get something that looks
like this where you can say oh,
I guess the problem is with that
crash button was pressed
method.  Why do I have this
method?  Make I should get rid
of it.  So that's what happens
when you upload the symbols
file.
When you want to test
crash reporting, it's a little
tricky just that if your app
crashes and you are running in
Xcode, Xcode will go in and
capture that in the debugger
which is what you want.  If your
app is crashing while you are
in the middle of development,
you want to be able to analyze
what's going on right there 234
in the debugger.  If you want
to test that crash report is
working by running a crash on
the app, run the app in Xcode,
make sure the latest version is
on the device or simulator.
Then hit stop in Xcode, and then
run again from the simulator of
the device and then generate a
crash and you can run it one
more time and it's on the last
run that Firebase crash
reporting will notice that your
app crashed the previous time.
The last time you can run it in
Xcode and you will see a console
message that says crash report
finished uploading which is
nice.  A quick note on logging.
So Firebase crash reporting also
allows you to record logs,
report those directly to the
crash reporting tool so that in
addition to getting a stack
trace for any crash you can see
what your user was using right
up to the point where the app
crashed so that you don't have
to, so you can analyze this and
be like, wow, my user is using
my app in ways I did not expect.
You can do this by explicitly
logging events to Firebase crash
reporting eecialg with FIR
crash log, the first one reports
to Firebase crass reporting.
The second spits out stuff to
the console.  Maybe for some of
you doing more sophisticated
logging like you have written
your own logging method you
could be like that's great I can
report my log messages to crash
reporting with a couple of
lines of code and voila, all are
being reported to my crash
reporting.
>> Or if you are using cocoa
lumber jack you can say that's
great, I can add in a logger
that will report to my crash
reporting tool and everything I
log will get logged to Firebase
crash reporting or whatever
crash tool I happen to be using.
This is great but I want to
point out one cautionary tail
that Doug and another def guy
pointed out is that you might be
logging things that you are not
expecting to get reported to a
crash reporting tool.  I print
out all sorts of debug info.
I print out a lot of information
all of the time because I'm
like, oh, I will see that while
debugging or it will stay local
on the user's device.  If you
are suddenly magically with a
couple of lines of code
reporting all of that
information to the crash
reporting law where perhaps
other people in your company can
see that because they have
access to that panel, just make
sure you are not leaking
information that you didn't
intend to.
If you are currently using
another crash reporting tool and
you have done this technique,
maybe go home and double check
you are not doing this.  Just a
recommendation.  I will talk
about dynamic links because I
think they are also kind of c
ool.  These are basically links
that work the way you want them
to on mobile devices.  So the
same link can take users to an
Android app if they have it
installed or a iOS app.  If they
don't have the app installed
they can take them to the
appropriate place in the app
store or the play store and if
you prefer you can take them to
a website instead if they don't
have your app installed.
One of the big advantages of
dynamic links is if you have to
take users to the app store
first, all of that link
information doesn't get lost.
You are basically Firebase
dynamic links can read in
whatever link brought your users
to your app in the first place.
That's generally good
information for you.  It's
probably a really important
signal for like what did the
user click on that made the them
so, you know, interested in
your app that they had to
install it because you can then
take the information and make
sure you are presenting relevant
information to your user right
away instead of just a generic
home screen.  So this is a
really good way to increase
retention, I encourage you to
kind of look into these if you
have email campaign or any other
way you are sharing your app
through a link.
So one question I sometimes get
is, okay, are dynamic links the
same as universal links and the
answer is mostly
no but kind of yes a little
bit.  You probably know about
universal links it's your way of
telling IOS instead of opening
this link in Safari, if my app
is installed open my app and
pass the link into it.  My Apple
app app will read in the link
and know what important stuff it
should be displaying.  And you
do this by  placing a little app
site association on your
website it works great.  This is
assuming you have a website
with content that mirrors what's
in your app.
You could use dynamic links the
same way, if the user clicks on
this link take them to my app
and some other website, but
generally speaking most use them
when they want to be more
aggressive about driving i
nstalls.  If you are creating
an exquisite pay installer app.
It will take your user to the
app store, make sure they
install your app and when they
open it for the first time it
says you installed the app
because you are interest in cat
facts here are cat facts right
away instead of  showing a
generic sign-in screen.  Games
are other good example.
There are a lot of games out
there that don't have c
orresponding content on the
website.  If this is you and
your website has a list of our
games and a jobs page, this is
another option where dynamic
links could be helpful if you
want to link to a particular
replay or a particular level or
something like that within your
game.  So how do they talk to
your app?  Basically two ways.
One way is custom URL schemes so
you will add your bundle ID as
your custom URL scheme if you
have done Google sign-in you
have done it before or if you
saw my last presentation, this
is familiar to you.
You will handle it in an open
URL call.  Within this open URL
call, the full URL which is the
full dynamic link will pass into
the dynamic links library and
you will say can you turn it
into a dynamic link object?  And
you will get back the object
which you can parse, analyze and
do whatever you need to respond
to that link or you will get
back null in which case maybe as
a Google  sign in URL or
Facebook sign in URL O
something like that.  And to
get this working you will need
to turn on the associated
domains capability and you will
need to make sure you add in
this sub domain.app.G L@domain
basically as a domain your app
can accept.
And this ABCDE will obviously be
a code that is specific to your
project when you create it in
the Firebase console.  Then you
will handle it the same way
except that you will handle it
through the continual user
activity method insteel of open
URL.  So you are saying I
thought you told me dynamic
links aren't the same as
universal links, what's the deal
1234?  We basically use
universal links to send
information to your site when
they click the dynamic link.
We create our own tiny website
with sub domain.app got GL and
we host our own
app association site.  So it's
completely up to you whether you
want to support yiewb versal
dlirchgs on your own side.
Maybe you do, and that's fine.
And maybe you don't and that's
also fine and maybe you don't
have a website and that's okay
too.  It doesn't matter.
So don't freak out about
universal links if you are like
we haven't gotten around to
setting that up.  You don't need
to.  You only need to make sure
your client is capable of
receiving them which means t
urning on that one switch in the
capabilities tab of Xcode.  One
last note on testing dynamic
links.  You can't cut and paste
them into Safari.  Safari will
act like your app is not
installed.  Instead what you
want to do is paste them
directly into an app like notes
and then you have the option of
editing these URLs if you want
to try different things an see
what happens and if you long
press on them you have the
option of whether you want to
open them in the app or see what
happens if the link goes to
Safari.
So you want to test the links,
put them in notes and let iOS do
its magic.  I will move onto --
15 anyone its.   15 minutes.
Firebase age let's you sign in
or letting your user add in the
user name and password that
Firebase manages for you so you
don't have to store pass words
on your server.  Generally
speaking when you sign in, you
will use something like Google,
Facebook, Twitter, and you will
get back I think this is user
Google 1, 2, 3, and here is
information you use to verify
it.  So you will send that
information down to Firebase and
say this is Google user 1, 2,
3, and Firebase will verify on
its end that this appears to be
the user that you say, and then
basically once that's done, you
will get back a Firebase user I
D.
And you will be able to sort of
access this user as a Firebase
user in the client.  And this
Firebase user looks the same for
all users no matter how they
signed into your app.  You can
treat this object basically the
same way and this user ID will
be unique across all of the
different ciber  sign in
providers.  You get a giant
random string that gets paired
with the user I D so you can
verify on future visits and this
is cached locally and all of
that done transparent to you,
you don't have to care about
that, but this is nice because
when the user comes back to the
device you don't need to sign
them into Facebook, Google,
Twitter, et cetera.  You have
the information on your device
locally to keep ciberring
signing them in.
If you want to post things on
Facebook or  You Tube you will
have to sign in to these other
services.  Firebase also s
upports the idea of anonymous
auth which is basically pretty
cool.  It allows you to sign in
the user anonymously.  You can
tell Firebase I have  anonymous
user and it will give you back a
Firebase user object and you
can let your user communicate
with Firebase the they way
normally do.
>> At a future point if the user
says I will sign in with
Facebook, you can tell Firebase
this anonymous user is also this
fab  Facebook user, and
Firebase will link the accounts
so if this the same user signs
in with Facebook on another
device, they will get all of
this i nformation.  And we do
the right thing where if this
user also happened to have
created another anonymous
account on that other device and
they say oh, yes, I'm also this
same Pheifer  Firebase will say
it looks like you have two
accounts you want to associate
with this account.  Let's give
you the information.  And the
nice thing about the flow is it
lets you, it basically gives you
the power to have your user use
the app and all of its features
without forcing them in through
a s ign-in flow.  It's great
for your users.  They often
don't want to sign in just to
try the app.  They are sort of
much more vested in the process
if they have tried it a bit and
they say I actually like this
app now I'm willing to sign in.
It's sort of, for you it makes
the process easier to handle
that and Apple generally likes
this approach as well.  They are
encouraging you to  can you
have the user try out the app
without signing them into a sign
in flow right away.  Try out
anonymous auth if you haven't.
It's neat.
I will move
on.  Firebase app indexing
which allows your app to show up
in Google searches.  So this is
like universal links, and my
answer is, no, but also yes a
bit.  So app indexing on iOS is
useful if you have universal
links set up where those links
point to your app.  We have the
website, you know, we have got
the website and the app and our
Apple site association file that
sells iOS instead of opening
links in Safari, open it up
directly in the app if it's
installed.  And so what you can
do is basically through one call
through app indexing, you can
let Google know that your app is
using universal links.  This
parameter  that you are passing
in is your app will iTunes.  ID.
store ID is incase we need to
grab information like your app
icon.  It let's Google know you
are using universal links
installed on your site and you
are okay with it reading that
file.
What happens is when your site
shows up in the search results,
Google will look at the link and
say, wait, I know that link
uses universal links.  And I
know the app is available on
this device, so I know that this
link is not actually going to
grow to a website.  It's going
to open in the app ininstead.
It will change the look to look
a little more appy.  And then
based on the assumption that you
have gone or your user has gone
through the trouble of i
nstalling the app in the first
place, that probably means they
are interested in the content of
your app.
And, therefore, this search
result might be a little bit
more relevant.  So you will
often not always, no guarantees,
get a ranking boost because
basically we now know that
things   this is going to an app
that the user installed and is
interested in.  The other
question is is this like core
spotlight and here the answer is
no.  App indexing is more for
Web content that you might be
searching for on Google and
letting Google know that those
links will show up in your app
at well.  Core spotlight is
letting spot light know you have
content available on the app in
the device and people can use
it using spotlight.
You can very clearly use both of
these if you feel they are
appropriate for your app and you
probably should because you
want your app to be
discoverable.  So let's talk
about Firebase Cloud messaging
which is our one stop messaging
solution for messaging on all
platforms.  The idea is you can
use Firebase Cloud m essaging to
communicate with Android as
well as route notifications
through APNS to stalk to iOS
devices.  How does it work?
Here is the 90-second summary.
Why would you want to do this?
Maybe that's a better question.
So basically part of the reason
is that you only have to write
one code path.  You only have to
talk to one service.  So that
gives you less code
to write.  There is less code
in general.  I guess that's not
true because we have to write
the code but you don't have to.
There is other reasons, you can
take advantage of services like
t opics, your clients can
subscribe to various
notification topics about
various subjects.  Your client
can say I'm interested in events
happening in Texas and then if
you want to send a notification
to everybody, you know, who is
interested in Texas events, you
can do that without having to
write server side code.  You
simply tell Firebase Cloud m
essaging, send this to people
who subscribe to the Texas topic
and it will do that.
It also lets you use Firebase
notifications panel which does
make this whole process easier
and I will talk about in a
minute because it is pretty c
ool.  All right.  Now, here is
the 90 second summary of how
this works.  Generally speaking
you will set up APNS and you
will have an APNS certificate
you will use to talk to the
server.  You are going to upload
APNS certificate to Firebase
cloud messaging.  It will
associate it with the same app
associated with the API key.
Assuming that your user has s
aid, yes, I would like to
receive notifications, will send
SAPNS .  So you will get back a
Firebase Cloud messaging token
and it will hold onto a copy of
the token and make sure it's
associated with the Firebase
Cloud messaging token.  When you
then ask to send a
notification, you will send it
with an API key and Firebase
will confirm that, yes, it
matches your app.
It will notice, hey, this
Firebase messaging device token
is associated with an
APNS t oken.  I I'll take that
APNS to talk to APNS and I will
take the token to identify the
object I want to talk to and put
that in a new notification I
will send to APNS and APNS ends
notice to your device.  Here is
how you do that work on the
client side.  You do this.  So I
am being a little fess E.
facetious.  You need to enable
notifications in your t ab.  But
basically this call does all of
the work needed on the client
to do that whole, h ey, let's
request a token from APNS and
give it to Firebase Cloud
messaging.  There are very
clever methods going on behind
the scene that's hides these
details from you.
At this point on your end
handling incoming messages are
like handling incoming
notifications.  There is very
little custom code you have to
write to get the app to work
with Firebase code messaging.
Now that I have told you that,
you will look at documentation.
I'll hold that thought.  I want
to point out the first thing we
are asking you for or that we
ask for is a silent n
otification.  That's important
because as a developer, you want
to decide when you are going to
ask for those more visible
notifications with the badges
and sounds and what knot.  I
think apps used to ask for these
on start up but users are like
why do you want to send me
notifications and they will
decline in large numbers.  The
best practice is for apps to say
we would like to send you
notifications for these reasons,
doesn't that sound great?  And
the user says that sounds
fantastic and you write the code
to bring up the system
dialogue.  So don't worry, you
can still do that using Firebase
Cloud m essaging.
So you don't have to write
custom code to get Firebase
Cloud messaging to work and then
you look at our documentation
and you will see the custom code
to connect Firebase Cloud m
essaging and you will say I
thought you said I didn't have
to do any of this.  The answer
is you can also send messages
through Firebase Cloud messaging
to your app if it is in the
foreground without having to go
through APNS or in addition to
going through APNS.  So why
would you want to do this?
Mostly for redundancy.
It also turns out that Firebase
cloud messaging tends to be more
aggressive about delivering
medium priority messages, but
it's about redundancy.  What
will happen within your app when
it goes into the foreground, a
little trouble clicking here.
When your app goes into the
foreground you will explicitly
connect to  to Firebase Cloud m
essaging.  When your app goes
into the background you will
explicitly disconnect.  That's
how Firebase Cloud messaging
knows whether or not to use the
channel to communicate to your
app.  The nice thing is  is
Firebase Cloud messaging does go
through the process of deduping
messages for you so from your
perspective p ks like you only
got un.
The other thing we have
announced around notifications
is the Firebase notifications
panel.  This makes it easier for
non-technical members of your
team to send notifications.
There will be times you will
need to write custom protocols
and server logic and that stuff
but this does cover a lot.
There are two things I want to
point out, the first is we can
target audiences to receive
notifications so I can send a
notification to people who have
bought stickers from my app
store in the past and tell them
we have new categories of
stickers, check them out.  And
we define conversion events so
we can see how effective a
notification was.  Basically
within Firebase Analytics if
there are important events you
want to track like the user
making a purchase or subscribing
to your newsletter or signing
up for a premium service or that
sort of thing you would
identify those as conversion
events and you can tell Firebase
notifications, hey, I would
like to identify this conversion
event as this successful
conclusion of this notification.
So for every notification you
send you can see the number of
people it got sent to, the
number of people who opened up
that notification or the number
of devices because the person
could have multiple devices and
then the number of times that
notification led to a conversion
event.  That's really useful in
case you are wondering if
notifications are being helpful
or not.
Are they  being spammy or h
elpful to the users you are
targeting.  You can look and see
how many are being opened, how
many are being acted upon and it
can help you realize either I
need to target my messaging more
or I am doing a good job.  So
that was a lot of stuff to cover
and  I haven't covered a bunch
of other  features yet like
Firebase storage and ad mob and
normally at this point I would
be p roducing pli rout 85 which
is my show on the You Tube
channel.  We started a brand new
You Tube channel for Firebase
so it's called Firebase, but you
can find it at You Tube.com/
firebase where we will be
hosting a bunch of screen casts
on how to get started with some
of these features both on iOS
and A ndroid.  As we start
building out libraries and
adding cool features and adding
new stuff they might get added
pretty f ast, but that's okay,
it keeps me in a job.
So if you want to find out m
ore, this is where you find
Firebase.  This is where you get
some nice help and support.  We
have got our You Tube channel,
our Twitter feed and with one
minute remaining I will say
thank you very much.  I will
take questions down here.
Thanks!
(Applause).
Engagement.
May 19, 2016. 2PM PT.
(Applause).
>> FABIAN SCHLUP: Hello,
everybody, thank you so much for
come ing today to the session.
My name is Timo, I'm a product
manager on Google Search. And
here with me, every       I have
Fabian who is a software
engineer who works on app
indexing. We're excited to talk
to all of you about app
indexing today. I'll start out
of        out with a quick
overview of what app indexing is
all about. How you can use
Google Search to get more active
users and keep those users
engaged. Then Fabian's going to
talk a little bit about how you
can get started with app index
ing.
We'll conclude with a very
excite ing outlook of what we
are going to do later this year
around personal content with a
couple of very excite ing demos.
Every day, users come to Google
billions of times with
information. And that happens in
many countries more often on
mobile than on desktop. Now,
your app can be relevant to
these billions of information
needs. Your app constantly can
help all of these users suck
come to us            cumb to us
with various needs they have.
Now, the question is, how can
you actually connect your app
with all of those users and
their needs? That's what we're
going to talk about today.
indexing. You can get your app
and its content into Google
Search. Acquire new users, yo uh
can experience
you can experience
organic growth and keep the
users engaged. Now, one of the
changes we've announced this
week is that app indexing is now
part of Firebase. Firebase is a
suite of IPD     integrated
products designed to help you
develop your app, grow user base
and earn money.
App indexing is one of 15APIs
that help you, the developers,
build amazing apps.
When      It can lead to more
active users. Together, with
your app content and Google
Search, we can delight all of
those users to come to Google
for various needs. Who here is
familiar with app indexing?
Awesome. It's a good number.
For those of you familiar with
it, you'll find that Fabian has
a couple of interesting changes
to announce. Now, for those of
you not familiar with it, don't
worry about it . With Firebase,
you have all of the tools you
need to get started at your
fingertips.
Next, let's talk about some of
the products we've built to help
you grow your app and keep your
users engaged. Let's start with
growth and installs through
Google Search. Now, here as you
can see on the search results
page, we can help you get your
app discovered. For very, you
know, specific search intents
such as IO2016, we can show you
results from apps such that you
can install that app. All I want
ed to do was install the app,
step on the green button, goes
to the play store, you can
download and install the app.
If I have more generic
information needs such as Google
Apps or race ing games, . Now
you     we can also help rank
these types of results better.
Now, having to install an app,
though, creates a lot of
friction between users and their
needs as well as, you know,
your app content. Now, yesterday
, a something was announced
ed   d excite ing, on the
it's an amazing new experience
that keeps
user -- now instead of having
to download a   an app first, go
right into the app where you
can find all of the information
that they need.
Now, this will ultimately reduce
this barrier that stands
between the user and your app
content.
Next, let's talk a little bit
about ENL     engagement and how
Google Search can help you with
that. Once an app is installed,
we can organically open in your
app. A search for IO schedule,
you can see it as a result from
the app, all I have to do now is
tap on it and goes right into
the app where I find all of the
information that I need. For app
indexing, again, you can -- we
can help you rank those results
better on the
search results page.
With the Google App, we've put
the power at the user's
fingertips with the search box
on many
android phones on the home
screen. Tap on the search box,
type it in and they're good to
go. Earlier today, I looked up
various sessions in the IO app.
My own session included. If I
want to get back to that session
, all I have to do is type in
rules, which is the title of the
talk. And I see the results
appear here while I type in the
Google App. When I type into
this, it goes back into the app
where it can find all of the
information such as
.
Now, the Google App helps re
engage users with the app
content for those
thousands of apps. And it's easy
for users to get back in.
Because all they have to do is
tap on the search box and tell
us what they're looking for.
Now, besides the search results
page and the Google App, Google
brings your app con at the
present time to users'
content
to the user's fingerprints. A
new movie "Captain county
America" that I should check
out. Now all I have to do is
press the home button and get
more information through Google
Now. Here, I get "Captain
America," and a couple of app
results, as well. These apps are
use ing App indexing. If I tap
on
the result, it goes into the
app where I find all of the
information that I need. It's an
amazing feature because it puts
your app content    tent
anywhere where they are on
android.
little bit. More than 10,000
apps are use ing app indexing to
grow their app and keep the
users engaged. But it includes
most of the top apps that users
use every single day all over
the world. It translates to more
than 200 billion app results
and a truly amazing number.
Let's look at some of the
success stories of partners that
are use ing app indexing.
Increase on CTR by almost 5% for
app results, access on increase
in daily ad traffic almost 12%.
And increased transaction value
by 200%.    are some truly
amazing numbers that tell you
how important app indexing is
for these partners and that any
app should use this technology
to grow the user base and keep
the users engaged. Now, with
that, I'm handing it over to
Fabian to tell you how you need
to get started.
>> FABIAN SCHLUP: Thank you,
Timo. So let's talk about what
you need to do and how you can
get started enable ing the the
great features that we saw
working for Europe. And as Timo
outlined, the key is really to
get your app into the google
search index. Once it's in
there, we can then surface
results for your app in great
places, like, Google Search, now
on tap, the autocomplete
feature. And we can bring YURS
users right into the
relevant screen in your app.
Over the last year, it's
actually gotten quite a bit
easier to index apps. That's
something we're really excited
about it. And you'll see that in
a moment when I step through.
There's three basic rules that
you want to follow if you want
to get
this engagement and growth for
your app. First, your app needs
to
support URLs so you can link
right into the right place.
Second, you need to call our API
so we can better understand the
content in your app. And three,
you want to make sure you can
keep an eye on, you know, the im
pact you're getting from
following the first two rules,
right? How many more active
users you're        you're gett
ing and if there's still room
for improvement optimization in
your app to get even more out of
it. We'll step through this one
by one in a second starting
with supporting URLs. Let's do a
quick show of hands, who here
has an app or worked on an app
that supports URLs? Oh, great,
about half. And how many of you
have worked on app indexing
specifically? So getting your
app into the index?
All right. Cool. Excellent. So
let's talk about URLs first. UR
Ls were invented for the web,
right? So websites support URLs
naturally. You have different
web pages. Each one comes with
their own URL. And that's what
you see in the address bar at
the top of the browser. But for
apps, it's a little less natural
to support URLs. And we really
have to think about and write
specific codes to actually
handle URLs in the apps and make
sure the right screen comes up
when your app is started with a
URL.    important
important to do that, right?
Because when we want to find
relevant content for our users,
we don't want to just send them
to your app, launch the app, but
take them straight to the right
place. So this is really one of
the building blocks of app
indexing.
Next, you know, there's a
question of if you have a URL
like the one on screen here, how
do you actually know there's an
app that can handle this type
of URL? How do you know this
might potentially link into an
app? And how do you find out
what that app might be?
the website with the app or with
a set of apps that can also
show that content. And it turns
out in the web, we have a very
very similar challenge
where a web browser needs to
find out
what web server to get the web
page you want to look at. When
you type a URL into a browser,
the browser uses something
called the domain name system or
DNS to result the domain name
into an IP address which tells
it what server to talk to.
That's worked really well for
the web. And over the last year,
we've seen a similar system
being established for
resolve ing a domain name into a
mobile app. And actually, it's
two systems. One for android and
one for I   iOS. They work
similarly. Almost identically.
And I'll step through exactly ho
ly   ly it works in a
moment.
What they do the systems is they
allow you to create a
connection, linking from your
website to the app and basically
declare ing, hey, this is the
app or set of apps that can
handle my URLs. And also, the
other way around, have the app
declare what are the kinds of UR
Ls I can handle. And with this
two-way connection, that's what
helps us understand the space.
So let's look at how the
this specifically works on
androids and then I'll go into i
OS second. And I'll continue to
use the IO app. Because many of
you might have that installed on
your phone today and you can
check out some of these things
right after the session
yourself. And then, also, we'll
be publishing the source code
for the IO app for     after the
conference so you can see the
implementation behind all of
this.
So every Ann destroyed
android app has
something, here's an example of
the I   man any fest,
NI        manifest, and
that's where it declares that it
can handle any URL in the
domain, events Google to come,
and that starts with the path I
O2016/schedule/anything. And
then, there's the little
attribute that you can see auto
verify equals true. That's a new
attribute from level 23 that
tells us that we have this two-
way connection set up. Meaning
that the system can go talk to
the website and the website will
very      verify and confirm
that, in fact, this is the app
that               S   that it
wants its URLs to link into. And
also, if you have this
attribute. What you'll actually
get starting from android 6.0
marshmallow, your app will be
set as the default handler for
these types of URLs right when
it's installed.
That means that even the first
time a user taps on the URL
anywhere on the phone, the
message ing app or web or
anywhere, they'll be taken
straight to your app, and they
won't get the dialogue that you
might know that will ask you if
you want to open this in the
browser or in this app. So
that's another great benefit you
get
there.
But for any of this to work, the
service side has to also check
out, right? The other connection
. The other side of the
connection. So how this works is
you host
a small predefined path on your
website that defers back to
the app by package name and
certificate fingerprints. And
that part is really important,
right? The google,       GOOG
Google to understand that
it's okay to link results from
search for these types of URLs
directly into this app. That's
something we don't want to do
unless we know the website owner
actually wants this traffic to
go into this particular app,
right? Instead of the website.
On
the IOS side, we have something
called entitlements. As part of
the app itself. And, again,
that's where you would refer to
the domain for which the app can
handle URLs. And on the service
side, again, a small chase on
file. Different one, but similar
in spirit where you point back
to the IOS app by iTUNZ    TUNZ
I-TUNZ        iTunes ID.
I do no    know an interesting
difference between the Io    io
OS and android system, the path
prefix that defines the set of U
RLs the app can handle is define
d with the server side
configuration file on iOS. While
on androids, this is part of
the app i   itself in the SBEPT
intent filter.
Now you've got this two-way
connection set up and of course,
you have to write the codes to
actually bring up the right
screen and so forth in your app.
And I'm not going to into
go into details about that right
here. But at least now we have
a clear system for finding the
right app to link into just give
given the URL. But until
recently, actually, many of us
have still been use ing custom U
RLs. And let me give you an
example of what I mean. By
custom URLs, custom keep
scheme. Not HD  DRKS     DDP.
These are broken in several
ways. I want to take a moment to
try to discourage you from use
ing these as much as possible,
if you can at all help it. One
of the issues here is that we do
not have the system here,
right? Where we can somehow re
liablely resolve any
ly    y resolve any part
of this to an app. It's not
clear which app this should link
into. And then also, it really
doesn't work across platforms.
So if you want to share this URL
with a friend, send them a
message or post this in social
media. You can't really, right?
Because if your friend opens
this on the mobile computer, on
desk top computer, rather, then
that's not going to do anything
on a desktop computer. And so in
these cases, you still have to
send a web URL which works
anywhere because it opens the
web page. But then, if your
friend does receive it on a
mobile device, then now that's
not going to go into the app,
right? Even if they have the app
installed. Now you would have
to translate from the web URL to
the custom URL and now you'd
have to have some sort of map
ping table or translation rule.
So long story short, by use ing
web URLs, HDDPURLs s, you can
sidestep a lot of the headaches.
And that's what I would
recommend.    your app does
support HDP URLs. Now you're
ready to test. And if you want
to test your app many ice LAX
solation, maybe UCHT
you haven't gotten the service
side launched yet. You can
launch your app with a view
intent and passing the URL you
want to test out. And that
should launch your app and get
you straight to the right screen
if if    you've done everything
right. And once you've got the
connection in both ways
established, if you have the
little file for android or iO,
S or both deployed on the
website . The easiest way is
probably to send yourself a
bunch of URLs in an email or
something and tap on them on
your device
. And then that should go
straight into the right screen.
you know, that is required for
your results to start showing up
on Google. It might still take
a day TWOR      or two for us to
pick it up and start showing
the results to users. In the
meantime, what you can do,
check out the brand new preview
tool. You can find this as part
of the documentation. We
LAUMPLGed it      ed
launched it earlier this week.
You can enter any of your URLs
and we'll instantly show you a
preview of how your results are
going to look like on mobile for
your users. That's kind of cool
.
So with that, let's go on to the
next slide and talk about the
second rule. Calling the API. As
a user uses your app and
browses the con at the present
time in                       t
ent in your app, you can call
the API with the URL and the
title of the current screen. And
that helps us better
better understand how your app
works and what content is
important to users. And that can
actually also be an interesting
signal for us to help rank
these results on Google Search.
And another place where this is
really important is the auto-
complete feature that Timo
showed you earlier. Here we have
limited real estate on the
screen. We can fit a max of five
or six results max. So we want
to show only the most relevant
results. And so, in this case
here, just knowing that I've
looked at my own SKEGS
session before in the I
O app, that's a strong signal
for us that there's, you know, a
lot of high likelihood I want
to get back there, right? That's
important content for me. And
that's what we would show in
auto-
E KPLOO       complete. And with
one tap, I'll be right back in
the app.
And in terms of the code we ask
you to add for this, it should
be fairly minimal.
It can basically be three lines
per activity or per time of
screen you have. The first one
is constructing the URL for the
current session. Again, this is
the example from
the IO app. Second, putting
together the action object with
a title and the URL that
describes what is happening. And
you see that we use the view
action here. We also support
other action types such as
listen or purchase or bookmark
depending on what it is the user
does. But viewing will be one
of the more common ones.
And then third, you call the
start method to indicate that
the action is now starting. And
there's a corresponding end
method, as well, that would be
called by the IO app as you
navigate away from the session
detail screen, again. And if you
have instantaneous actions in
your app, like, you know,
bookmarking something or
purchase ing something, then you
can just call the end method
straight away and be done with
it.
And to make it, you know, as
simple as possible to do this,
we've added to the studio one of
the things the studio will do.
It'll tell you if there's any
issues with, both your
implementation
of URL support in general or
your implementation of calling
the API. It'll also help you
generate the codes, and also
most of the intent filters. And
then you can also test right
from within Android Studio. We
have a feature where we can
simulate
with a given URL and Android
Studio will show you which
parameters and     for API and a
little preview of that page in
your app. On the iOS side, the A
PI is simpler and more limited
currently. We ask that you add a
single call when the app starts
up to register the app
on the device.
And so now you already essential
ly know everything there is to
get your app into the index. And
now, you really want to make
sure it actually worked, right?
And you're actually getting more
active users and you want to
see if there's any issues or
maybe what you can optimize to
get even more out of this. One
thing you definitely want to do
is track refer traffic.
Through google      GOOG
How many users use through
Google. And a way to make this
simpler or to make it simpler
for you, we've added this method
. A little over a year ago with
level 22. And you can think of
it SLAer to the
similar to the HDP header. It
tells you where the user is come
ing from in terms of URL. If a
user's come
ing from Google.com in a web
browser, then the refer will be
Google.com. And if the user's
come ing in through the Google
app, which could be any
autocompletions or now on tap
all of these things, then the UR
L would be the second URL. The
Android dash app notation is a
way we use to put both a package
name and the URL inside the app
into one URL.
So if your traffic is not come
ing from any of these to
reverse, you know the user came
in through Google, and you can
log it through your analytic
solution. If you don't have an
analytics solution yet, by the
way, you might have heard about
this new offering launched
yesterday, Firebase analytics
which offers unlimited reporting
for free your app, that might
be a strong candidate to
consider here. ' And then from
our
And from our side, we offer
analytics. We have a tool called
search console, and you can
verify that you own a given app.
And then we'll show you metrics
on, you know, how many results
are we showing for your app? How
many clicks are these results
getting? And also, how many
installs are happening
happening as a result of people
that are discovering your app
on Google Search? And that's
basically it.
Make sure to support URLs, and
many of you already do. Second,
call the app indexing API so we
can better understand the
content and we can better rank
your results. And if you already
support URLs in your apps, this
is really the only rule you
have to follow in addition,
basically. And then three, make
sure to log into the search
console to see if you have any I
guess         issues and to see
the benefits that you're
getting and what you might
potentially be able to optimize.
You can find all of
this and more. But before you do
that, I'm going to give it back
to Timo for the excite ing last
part.
>> TIMO MERTENS: Thank you so
much, Fabian. I hope everything
everybody knows a
little more now what it takes to
get your app and its content to
Google Search. Now, we'd like
to talk about something very
special that's going to come
later this year that resolves
around personal content
volves
around personal content. So far,
we've talked about how to get
your public app content to
Google Search to grow your user
base and keep your users engaged
. But every day, users all over
the world interact with or
KREAKT        create a lot of
personal information whether
that's messages that you send or
receive, documents you create,
play lists you listen to or
photos that you take. Now, all
of that data is really important
for many, many different user
needs. For example, wouldn't it
be amazing if you could find
that message from a best friend
who talked about an awesome
sushi place. Wouldn't it be
great to find a shopping list
when I'm at the grocery store?
Wouldn't it be awesome if I
could just get back to that play
list before my Sunday morning
run?
No, your app content can help
with many of these different
user needs. And that's why we're
excited to announce today that
later this year we're going to
let your index personal content
on android. We're going to ex
tend app indexing to let users
find anything in their apps
through the Google App.
Now, when we design this
addition to app indention
dexing, we follow three core
principles. Which are privacy
control and simplicity. First of
all, personal app content stays
on the device and doesn't leave
the phone. It means, we will
search the data on the phone.
Next, you as the developer will
be in crop of the life cycle of
that data. You determine when it
gets indexed, updated or remove
d.
Finally in regards
ly   ly, advance once more.
There you go. Fabian explained
how easy it is right now to get
the con at the present time to
google      GOOG      Google
Search, a few lines of code and
keep it as simple as that. Just
a few lines of code and your
personal content will be indexed
on the phone.
Now, let's look at some of the
cool experiences that we could
actually enable with that
addition.
Some very special partners.
All right. Fair enough. So my
friend Henry sent me a message
before telling me about a great
session I should check out on
Friday. Totally forgot the title
for it. Let's see if we can go
back to that. All we have to do
is tap on the search box here.
Tap on the search box. And all
we have to do is type the name.
I don't know if we can adjust
the -- we're good with time.
We've got a few minutes.
use the device itself.
>> TIMO MERTENS: Excellent.
>> FABIAN SCHLUP: Better?
>> TIMO MERTENS: Is that better?
No? Maybe? A little bit?
A little darker still.
How many developers does it
take to fix it?
We need more people on stage,
apparently, to fix this.
>> FABIAN SCHLUP: Maybe you
could talk through what happened
.
>> TIMO MERTENS: All right.
>>
>> FABIAN SCHLUP: People have
seen the auto-complete feature.
Just close your eyes and --
>> TIMO MERTENS: Imagine. That's
right. What I wanted to do was
find a message from my Henry was
talking about this session I
should check out. All we have to
do is demonstrate, type the
name in the search box. And
normally you
see completions for that. And
instead what we will show is a
contact card for the contact as
well as a message from that app.
In this case, Henry sent the
message. And all we would have
to do is tap on the result and
goes right into the app. And can
then read the message in that
conversation. And now that seems
to be better.
>> TIMO MERTENS: We just go for
it and you have          you
have to imagine you see the
things on ZBREEN        screen.
>> FABIAN SCHLUP: We'll do it
like this. Thank you.
>> TIMO MERTENS: Once more.
Let's try this one more time.
Henry and --
(Laughter).
>> TIMO MERTENS: You see an icon
over there, that's a good start
. Just tap on the results and we
go right into the app.
And a little purple, that's
good. But anyway, Henry's tell
ing me to check out Google's
vision tomorrow morning at 9:00
a.m.. Sounds like a great talk
you should totally check out.
Now, this is going to be really
tricky. But -- all right. We
need to go down a little bit to
see what else. There you too
see the vision. Going into the
next one. If we got back to the
home screen, now -- by the way,
who went to the concert last
night? Awesome. It was amazing,
wasn't it? Now, we happen to go,
as well. And Fabian sent me a
message, actually, with a video
he took. Now, all we have to do
is search for Fabian and see
there's a message in glide
Glyde, LETSZ see if
, let's see if we can play
that back. Looks like a lot of
fun. Awesome.
Now, going back to the previous
message, tomorrow morning, 9:00
9:00 a.m., I remember I had
breakfast planned with Adam.
Let's try to find the message,
I've totally forgot the time.
Then we tap on it, search for
Adam.
>> FABIAN SCHLUP: Adam.
>> TIMO MERTENS: There it is.
The message in linkedin. Tap on
it, jump right into it. And
there       there we go. 8:00
a.m. on Friday. Thank you.
Now 8:00 a.m., I guess I have
to get up earlier tomorrow. Fair
enough. I love eating yogurt
for breakfast. The other day I
started reading an article call
ed how yogurt affects the brain
that I never finished reading,
but I did save that one and
in pockets. Now if I want to go
back to it, all I have to do is
type in part of the title and we
can tap on it and goes      it
goes right into the app where I
can go ahead and read it on my
way home tonight. Thank you,
Fabian. Sorry for the technical
difficulty ies.
Now, these examples really show
the power of that data and user
needs. Through the Google App,
we can let users find everything
in their apps with their
personal life with their
personal data or through the
Google App by tapping on the
search box, type ing in a few
characters and they see your app
content right there. And all of
this will be powered through
App Indexing later this year.
Now, here are the partners we've
worked with in the early access
program. They've done an
amazing job in and able ing the
experiences and
e ing
enable ing these services. If
you're interested in this, have
a look at this link here and
share your interest with us
later this year. We will follow
up with more information or
availability of this extension
of app indexing. Now, quick
summary, we showed that with App
Indexing, you can get more app
users, grow your app, drive
reengagement all through these
various search features, such as
the search results page or
instant apps. Fabian explain LD
three              PLAN
plained three simple rules
that's all it takes and later
this year, you'll see some
really cool features around
personal con at the present time
tent.
Now, here's more information
about both app indexing as well
as Firebase, come check with us.
We're happy to talk more with
all of you. And with that, thank
you all so much for come ing.
We hope you're as excited about
getting your app into search as
we are. Thank you.
(Applause)
time for questions if anybody
has some.
>> FABIAN SCHLUP: Yeah.
>> TIMO MERTENS:
>> TIMO MERTENS: Go ahead.
>> I love it, it's great. I've
been implementing it in all of
my apps. Through the
personalization, looks like you
can add more content besides the
title. That's like one of the
largest features that's missing
compared to core spotlight
search. And it seems like you
guys are addressing that for
personal. Seems like since the
Google App could just update and
you can update the SDK, are we
going to see that for
nonpersonal? Rile      Right
now, just icon, icon, icon. It'd
be lovely to see your beautiful
faces when I look for App
indexing and then a tiny icon,
per se, so they know what app it
is. Is that stuff in the works
or all in the personal stuff?
>>
>> TIMO MERTENS: Overall, we are
expanding on the features that
will highlight con at the
present time. You just saw an
early stage integration, but
there's much more to come later
this year.
>> Okay. That was very vague.
>> TIMO MERTENS: Talk later.
>> FABIAN SCHLUP: Maybe I can
and     add that, yes, showing
more interesting, engage ing,
richer results is something we
think about. For personal
content, that's -- we're going
to have to, you know, we're
going to need your help for you
to actually provide us some of
that data through the API and
for, you know, for the more
public content that we have
today. We actually don't want
you to make us pass more
information or we don't want you
to have to do more work. We
have more information of more
rich results we could show.
>> Hi, so I had a question about
turning on and off app
indention       dexing. You can
do that for personal content.
But can you do that for web
content for the classic search
indexing?
>> FABIAN SCHLUP: Your question
is as an app owner, can you turn
on or off
ommunication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
********
>> There we go.
Good afternoon.  Welcome to
Firebase notifications.
(laughter) In this session,
I'm Francesco, I'm going to
introduce why we believe that
notifications are important.
Later on, Tingmui,
our project manager will come on
stage and introduce what we
have built so that you can use
notifications effectively.  And
finally,
Laurence, our lunch and T shirt
guy and developer   eradicate
will show you this product with
a few demos.  So let's begin.
Why notifications?  When we
embark on the journey of d
eveloping an application, we all
dream about its success.  We
think about how
much our use ers will love our
applications.  We want them to c
ome to the application and want
more and more.  Because user
engagement play
AIs
really big role in application
development.  Applications are
those messages that comes in
front of a use er, grabs their
attention, and
hopefully do something that we
want to.  A month ago I bought a
ticket to a fest I feel
festival and this
application is reminding me that
in three days
this application begins and
maybe I should check the final
line-up or buy tickets
tickets to the shuttle or share
the notifications with my
friends.
So notifications are really
important in fact there are
study ies         study ies that
show that use ers that opt into
notifications are twice as
likely to
come back as those that don't.
But if we send too many
notifications
notifications, we might upset
the use er, overwhelm them and
achieve the opposite
effect.  Use ers might silence
notifications or even worse,
uninstall or app.  So we need to
get a few things right.  We
need to know, when is
the rate time to get        to
send a notification.  If I get
the notification now to come
back and play a new level, it's
probably not effective.  We
need to understand who we should
target.  If we have wet suit
sales, and we target runners,
maybe we are not as effective as
if we target
surfers.  And finally, what is
the member?  What are we trying
to -- message we are trying to
convey to this use er.  If we
write an
application and slip in a bug,
bug zapping, right.  We
definitely have bugs in our
applications.  Not Laurence.
Obviously not Laurence.
Well we want to target just
the population that was affecte
d by the bug.  We don't want to
send an apology to the entire
population of
our use ers.  So, notifications
are really important, but to get
these things right, we need
some sort of feedback, and here
is when analytics
comes to help.  Because with g
ood analytics data, now we can
improve our engagement statute
us.  And our
marketing and growth people can
spend time focusing on how to
increase our use er base and our
content editor can send content
updates as they write the
articles.  And our
product managers like Tingmui
here can send announcements to
use ers that will make the usage
of the April even      -- app
even more compelling.  So we
think this is very important and
here at Firebase, we have a new
product that will let you do
exactly this.  Please welcome T
ingmui to show
you Firebase notifications
notifications
(Applause)you, Francesco.
So, let's take a look at five
base notifications.  It is part
of the Firebase product.  And
Firebase is a
integrate ed product that helps
you to develop your apps, glow
a use er base, and earn money.
Francesco just mentioned that
notification is really important
in helping you to engage use
ers.  With the right contacts,
and the right analytics, it
could be even more
powerful.  But the process has
to be simple.  So that people
can really focus on getting the
content of the message.  Send an
interesting
message that's going to bring
your use er back much more
effectively,
so let's see how Firebase
notification is going to help
you achieve that
that.  Many of you are familiar
with Firebase Cloud message ing.
The new version of Google
Cloud message ing.  It has been
reliable y delivering
messages to Android, iOS, and
Chrome use ers.  Firebase
notifications is built on top of
Firebase Cloud Message ing.  It
is cross-platform.  It
is designed so that you can set
the right target are the right
contacts and be able to evaluate
effectiveness after.  It's
simple.  As you
can see from this console anyone
should be able to send a
notification on message without
having to write a single line of
server code so
that you can really focus on
getting the content of your
message right.
But, it is not just a forum
so that you have to fill out
all the mandatory fields before
you can send a message.  It's
designed so that
you can set the right target by
using analytic insights, SCM
topics or even device and app
info.  Once you have these lined
to the right
target, it's about engage ing
engage ing your use er
with the right contacts.  For
example, use language so that
you can localize your message so
that your
Italian use ers will not be
getting a German message, for
example.  Or send your message
so that it's delivered based off
the use er's time zone
zone.  Don't have to worry about
wake ing a use er at 3:00 a.m.
in the morning, get them mad,
turn off notifications and
potentially say bye to
your applications.  Every
applications has its own
customizations and you can do
that by using the custom data
field.  You can pass in the
dynamic length so you can take
use ers to the right content
hand the right flow of your app
or provide a discount so you can
apply the
discount when you tap on pending
notifications
.  You've just seen how easy it
is to send notifications but is
it a factor?  Is it bringing
more use ers
back?  Not having much of a
difference or actually turning
use ers away?
Firebase is integrate ed
with analytics and provide you
with a default analytics so you
can understand the effectiveness
right out of the   When sending
a message, a lot of the time
there is a goal that we want to
achieve.  You can set that by
using conversion events.  We
track sent and opened for you by
default, but obviously, you can
provide your own.  So now,
let's go take a look at the
console and see
where you can find the analysis
. to the laptop.
.  So, what you're --
(laughter).  So what you're
seeing here is the Firebase
console.  And you can find
notifications under growth
because we believe that it can
really help you to reenengage
your use er to improve the
experience.  So this is
where you have all the campaigns
that you're manage ing.  If you
click on one of the campaigns
that has already been completed,
it's loading.
All right.  This is where you're
going to see the analysis, the
notification funnel.  So there's
some interesting data here.
Number sent,
and how many of your use ers
actually haven't opened your
notifications.  So apparently,
this particular promotion is not
as effective in
getting the us auto -- use er to
open notifications and if you
actually put in 95s we will
track the time your use er a
ctually clicked the
actions that will lead to that
event.
So this gives you the basic
insight of notification effect
iveness.  If you want do more
analysis, this is when you go to
analytics.  So
there's one trick I would like
to share
with you here today.  So if you
go to analytics, and look for
notification opens under the
events
top, this will bring you the
default analytics event report
view.  So you see the total
count.  The breakdown by
messages and topics, as
well as the breakdown by
location and demo graphic if
those data is available to you.
The trick I want to show you is
if you actually click
on one of the messages up here,
we'll actually automatically
apply filters to all the
dashboards and all the event
reports in analytics.  So
now you can really do some
serious analysis of how this
particular notification campaign
actually impacts your underline
success metrics and
factors.  So now let's go back
to the presentation, please.ll
right.  So you've just seen the
product walk through.  So now,
Laurence, our develop eradicate
is going                   er
advocate is going to show us our
demo.
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: I don't
know about you guys but I'm a
really lazy code er
.  I like to write as few line
as possible.  Actually, before
my demo -- who?  I see people w
aving.  Oh, short.  So I'm a
very lazy programmer in general.
I like to write as few lines
of code as
possible.  I want things made as
easy as they can be and that's
one of the things that really
attracts many he to Firebase
notifications
because it's just so easy's
developer.  So first of all I
want to talk about two scenarios
for building applications and
one is when you're
receiving notifications in the
background and I want to talk
about just how easy it is for
you to build the code doing that
.
Here's the code if you want
to receive background
notifications in iOS.  Any other
lazy developers here?  You
know, a single line of
code, and technically, it's not
even a line of code.  It's a
line of configuration, right?
You add a single part to your
iOS application
and use the Firebase message ing
part -- a lot of people ask,
well why message ing?  Why not
notifications?  And you may be
familiar with Google
Cloud Message ing and now its
new evolution of Firebase
message egg.  So they're so
similar, we decided there's no p
oint in using two
different things so if you
incorporate the pod into your
Cloud message ing you can also
grow Firebase message ing as
well but all you've got to
do is put this in your
application and you're good to.
For Android, it's almost as
easy.  Just Firebase message ing
3.0.0.  And that's it.
So if you create an application
and I'm going to demo in just a
moment where I used Android
studio and I did file name
application and if
you're an
Android studio developer you're
probably familiar with the
template which just gives you a
hello world.  That's all I did
then add
added a line to the build.
gradele.  So I have an app
running and Tingmui is going to
send a notification to this app.
>> TINGMUI LI: Can we switch
to the laptop?
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah, s
orry.  Switch to the laptop.
>> TINGMUI LI: All right. So
let's see.  Let's start sending
a notification.  What shall I
send?
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: What
should we say?  What kind of
notification?  Just so you know
it's real.  Any hockey fans
here?  Who's going to
win the Stanley cup
?  Penguins?  Who said the
Seattle Thunderbirds?  You're my
hero.  They're not even in it.
Okay, let's send penguins.
>> TINGMUI LI: Penguins.
Hey.
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Easier
this way.  All right.  So can we
switch back to the phone?  So,
now, earlier you saw the phone
was just
sitting on the desktop and the
notification has just come in.
You can see it up in my
notification tray so if I slide
down from that, my
application was just called
Firebase notification one, and
you can see Tingmui has actually
sent the notification Penguins
and if I touch on
that, it's going to launch the
app.  And this is the familiar
app from hello world studio.  I
wrote no code to goat that.
Isn't -- get to
that.  Isn't that pretty cool,
right?
(applause)
I've never had so many
applause for doing nothing
before.  This is great.
(laughter)
Could so can we switch back
to the slide, please?  So that
was background notifications and
people say, great, but what if
I want do it
in the foreground.  The classic
example of this is if you're
using some kind of IP telephone
y app and then you want to
change your call, in
most cases you want to answer,
some you want to ignore, and
that you will kind of UI so
you're changing the context of
the app upon
receiving notification.  So
let's take a look at how to o
actually do this.  In this case,
I'm still a lazy developer so
it's not a whole
lot of work but it's a little
bit of work and it's a little
bit more so in Android, here's
all have I to do.  Okay I'm
going to create a class, because
I'm a lazy programmer and have
no imagine ation on what to call
the thing and I specify an
intent filter on this so
that will handle different
actions so this class will
handle the action and the action
I want it to handle is come
Google message ing app.  If
this application is running on
the device, whenever an income i
ng notification comes then this
Firebase message ing service
class is the one
that's going to handle it.
And this class would look a
little bit like this.  So it's
just straight forward Java code
here.  This is my lazy Java-b
ased message ing
service and I'm going to extend
the Firebase ed message ing
service for that.  And whenever
I receive the message, I just
receive this message
receive ed and it's going to
contain a remote message and
then there's a bunch of
attributes of that message that
I can do something with.  I
put together a screen cast of
this that went on YouTube last
night and one question somebody
asked me was well, how would I
generate a
custom noise so say, for
example, Android M, we have the
ability do a custom notification
.  Here's how you do that.
You're receiving the
remote message in and then you
can generate a new notification
that      that you would then
generate an Android with that
custom on L. also, if you
have Android Wear a watch next
to it, you can send the 95
there.  Lots of great stuff you
can do and this is really all
the code that you
have to be able to do do that.
You create the service.  You c
reate the message ing field.
Message received.  Pretty
straight forward.
Pretty easy, right?  And then
people go, but what about iOS.
I say, okay.  IOS.  Forgive
me, my
slides, I tend to use objective
C.  I haven't become a fan of Ta
ylor Swift yet.  People are
laughing
at my jokes.  This is great.
Last time nobody was.  So when
you're writing an iOS you just
have, have a receive line
line of code.  If you're an
objective C programmer you're
familiar with this.  It's just a
set of name value pairs.  So
there's going to be a set of
name value pairs
and keys, this is where I r
eadout the keys like maybe the
message ID or message body or
something like that and then I
can do something
interesting with that in iOS.
So should we see this in
actions?  What do you think?
>> TINGMUI LI: Why not?
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Okay.
Can we switch to the laptop, p
lease?  Actually, switch back to
the phone first, please.  And I
have my
application running in the
foreground and it's the same
hello world application from
Android studio except I added a
service class to that ll the
code I showed you on the slide
and I'm reasoning it and now can
we switch to the laptop, now?
What should we send?  What do
you think?  Something other than
Penguins.  I don't really like
the Penguins.
>> TINGMUI LI: Turtles
turtles?
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: There's
tho hockey team called the
turtles, but that's
okay.  Name a hockey team.  Is
he        sharks.  Thank you.  T
hey're going
to win tonight, right?  So as
Tingmui sends that, can we now
switch to the phone?  And we
should see an income ing
notification that's going
to change my activity.  Drum
role, everybody.  Thank you for
the drumroll.  There it is.  We
see this activity and this was
launched in
response to the notification so
in that slide where I showed you
earlier on that I received the
notification and I received the
data, I have
another activity that
I just launched, stuck that
bundle in the data.  So in this
activity I ran the text.  It was
really, really as simple
as that.  We're probably talking
15 lines of code total to do
the whole thing and this is me
receiving custom notifications
and actually
doing something active with
that.  How easy is that?  What
are we going to do year?  So
with that, Tingmui, I'd like to
pass it back to you
and we're going to talk about
some customers, right?
>> TINGMUI LI: Yep. Can we
go back to the presentation,
please?  And thank you, Laurence
.
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Thank
you
.
(applause)
got the T shirts.
>> TINGMUI LI: Yeah I think
we have more shirts to send out.
Okay.  So I hope you guys
enjoyed the T shirts as well as
the demo that we
just showed you.  We definitely
like it.  So we have just shown
you how to send this out without
using the console and how
simple it is to
integrate on the client side.
We don't want the developer
product in a vacuum so we have
been gathering a lot of
developer feedback and
there are many developers who
actually integrate ed to
Firebase notifications already.
Today, I would like to share
the experiences of three
of them and for the rest please
go to other Firebase sessions
and hear about their experience.
So, first, avenue air.
Someone is taking a picture.
So, avenue air helps use ers to
manage their travel experience
after they have
already booked their experience.
So they would get
a Firebase Mejia letter
message alert.  They
were also able to focus on the
important part      parts of
their
app.
Bus buzz.  An application t
hat allows you to book a bus
ticket.  They were able to
integrate very quickly with
Firebase while still
able to customize their use er
experience.
Milan studio is able to use
Firebase applications in their
latest application, true day, an
application that helps use ers
to celebrate
anniversary ies.  They have use
ers around the world and they're
able to use a time zone feature
so they don't have to worry
about sending
notifications
notifications after midnight and
disrupting their use ers so
these are some real life
examples and testimony ies on
how flexible, simple, and
reliable Firebase notification
is.  So we have covered a lot
today.  We've talked about why
we think 95 is
notification is important in
engage ing
use ers, what we built to engage
use ers, and also showed you
some demos and also partner
feedback.
In summary, there are three
key takeaways.  We built
Firebase notification so that
anyone can send notification
without having to write  line of
server code and we made the
client integration super simple
as well so that you can focus on
getting the right user with
the right contacts.  And with a
tight integration with analytics
, you'll be able to measure the
effectiveness of your
notifications.  We're
really excited to announce that
Firebase notifications is
available to you today, so for
those who are interested to
learn more, please go
to Firebase.
Google.com, check out our
documentation and support page.
We really look forward to your
feedback because we want to
develop a
product that really helps you to
better engage your use ers.  So
thank you so much for coming to
this session and now I'm going
to invite
Francesco back on stage and then
open up the floor for
questions.
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Before
we take questions I have a q
uestion for everybody here and
I've got I a couple of prizes of
some Chrome casts
casts, that anybody who's an
eagle eye developer.  You saw we
did our agenda slide, we did a
little bit of code but there was
a bug in that
code that wouldn't compute.  So
if anybody gets it, see me after
the session and you'll get a
Chrome cast for the first two.
So what
questions?  Now they're all
wondering.  Can we go to the mic
in the center.
>> Greetings. Yesterday when
I heard about Firebase for the
first time, I understood it was
for Android, iOS, and also
desktop message ing
messaging.  Does anything you
covered today cover that?
>> TINGMUI LI: So what we
have for Firebase notification
is iOS and Android today.  We
are definitely looking into
making it available
for web as well.
>> But not today?
>> TINGMUI LI: Not today.
>> Hey there, for the first
notification demo you did the
one that was just kind of
sending it directly.  I know you
said it's just like
one line of configuration code.
Was there also code for r
eceiving the notification that
we didn't see?  Like, how does
it know, then, which
activity to open up to or how to
send a bundle of data or how
that bundle of data gets read?
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah, so
that app was in the background
and all I did was launch the app
and whatever activity was on, I
touched the
home screen so then the app was
sitting in the background as a
result so then when I receive ed
the notification I just
reactivated the app.
In this case, it was pretty
straight forward but a
multiactivity one then whatever
activity is active at the time I
put it in the background
but no other code.
>> So that background was in
the background, we wanted it
reactivate it.  If you wanted to
send data, that's when you do
the foreground?
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Correct.
Exactly.
>> Hi. We saw the
notifications manually using the
console, but is there any way
to automatically trigger using
another app without the console?
To do notifications., I
misunderstood the question.  So
I want to use a second app to
trigger notification in my app?
>> Yes. Using for Firebase.
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: One
thing you could do is not
Firebase notifications but
Firebase messages and your s
econd app to send a
notification to Firebase message
ing and ask that to do that and
then if your first app was a
part of that.
>> But can we use the
audience analytics to send
notifications to different
audience?
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Yes you
could.  Definitely.
>> Hi there. Actually, I ha
ve my own app that I create ed
recently and I implemented that
goes with Cloud Message ing
there, and then I
rolled a PHP administration
panel for sending notification
to already registered use ers so
the thing I manage ed to do u
sing it that way, I was
also providing for user like an
action in the notification, so
that whenever the notification
came, there was like a bottom
button, for
example, refreshing data,
answering the message, or
anything like that.  How do you
implement that using Firebase?
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Corks
within the pay load          --
so, within the pay load you had
some data and you would use that
data to trigger an action
within your application?  So, in
the case, for example, the
second demo I sent there, that
data, Tingmui just sent Sharks
but that data
could be anything.  It doesn't
have to be the simple string
like that and whatever the
concept for that data, I could
parse that from the
client's side and say, if it's
sharks, launch this activity.
If it's ping      penguins,
launch that.
>> Yeah, but this is done
automatically.  When we have
sharks, we are running this
activity.  When there is penguin
, this activity.  But
I'm asking a possibility of
performing some act by the user
when the notification arrived.
So we see the notification, can
click the
notification to open the
default, actually open the
activity, but current solution
allows us to have a small button
or small action to
perform different action.  Like
snooze.  Like replay.  Something
like that., so that's something
that we don't have right now.
Yeah, but we're definitely
looking at getting it, Yeah.
Because
a lot of people ask about that.
>> All right. So another s
mall question, could you just
confirm that      that we can
use a solution like fire bird
notification
for the jell yes    y
bean, lower than the N?  Is it
usable there?
>> FRANCESCO NERIERI: Yes.
As long as you have the latest P
lay services version.
>> All right. That's all.
Thanks.
>> Thank you.
>> All right. I have two
questions.  The first one is
that I recently implemented the
GCM support for Android.  We're
talking about
.
Super
charge ing Firebase with Google
Cloud.
Test
FB28
.
May 19, 2016
>> Hello, everybody.
Welcome.  So today my name is
Sandeep.  It's always Sandeep.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Cloud platform.
>> BRET McGOWEN: I'm
alts a developer at Google for
the Google Cloud Platform.
>> SANDEEP DINESH:
Today we'll talk about
super
supercharge ing Firebase.have
had had a chance to
play with fieb previously?  A
good number.  You know it's a
integrate ed suite of products
to help you develop your app,
grow your user base and earn
money.  As a developer my
favorite part is how quickly
you can build amazing
applications without write ing
a single line of serve er side
code.
>> SANDEEP DINESH: When
you do need serve er side
code, Google Cloud Platform
comes to the rescue.  It's a
full Sued of tool, big data,
you name it.  It makes
super
supercharge ing your app really
easy.
>> BRET McGOWEN: So
today we're going to talk about
how fieb and Google Cloud
Platform are best friends.  How
they can work together to help
you build amazing things in
record time.
>> SANDEEP DINESH: So
we brainstormed and thought
about all the crazy ideas we
have.  We started throwing
them on the board.  We said
we're going to build a app that
does all of thoos things?  All
of these things?     Okay of the
we don't have that
much time.  Can we pick a hand
68.    ful?  Let's not get too
crazy
crazy.
>> BRET McGOWEN: Well
let's pick a few things.
We're going to build a app that
does a few of these crazy
things.  You know, I'm kind of
tone ed down a little bit.
But what we wanted to do is
build a realtime, crowd-source
ed
crowd-sourced, live-streamed
game ing        game ing
platform.
(Applause).
>> SANDEEP
DINESH:  That was a lot of buzz
word,
what does that mean?  What it
means is instead of a normal
game setup where each player
has their own character,
everyone is going to be playing
the same character at the
same time.  You might have seen
twitch plays Pokiman
popular a couple years ago.
Here is how it work, everyone
logged in, tab let, mobile,
desktop, they're all sending
commands, up down, left, right,
right, left, and the
character is responding to
every single one of them.
Sounds a little bit chaotic,
but a lot of fun.o, of course,
the fieb      Firebase real
realtime database is perfect
for this.  Makes making real
realtime crowd-source ed
applications very simple simple.
Let's take a look.  I built a
simple chat app every time I
sent the message with my phone,
you can see the chat
messages showing up in both
browse ers.  You can also see
the
chats coming
in the Firebase dashboard.
What is this data?
It's just JSON, makes it really
easy to intd grate
integrate into any
application.
>> SANDEEP DINESH:
Let's talk about code.  How do
you connect a Firebase.  When
you create a Firebase project
of information.  A API key, a
database URL, he's following
along, and a project ID.  You
use these three things to
connect a Firebase and also use
the API key and project ID to
connect to Google Cloud
Platform, so it makes it super
super seize ee.  You
take the
configure, pass into Firebase,
get a reference to the
database.  Then we get a
reference to the chat note.
Firebase is just basically a
tree of data.  So we've got a
node called chat.  We're going
to be inserting chat message
each chat message will be a
child of the chat node.
So how do we get the data
into Firebase?  Super easy.
Firebase provides a method
called push.  It automatically
appends your data to the list.
It creates a new child and
creates a unique ID for you.
This is really nice in our
multiplayer environment because
you're going to have a lot
of messages coming in at the
same time.  You won't have to
worry about stepping on each
oh, getting conflicting IDs or
create ing some sort of
timestamp on your phone, are
Firebase
does that for you.  You pass in
a ID you want.  In this
case we do a JSON, and then
text Google hello I/O.  Just
like that it instantly goes
into Firebase.  How do we
listen to the events as they
come in?  Firebase provides a
few event listener, one is
called Child added.  If you're
listening to the chat node, any
time there is a message
that comes under that, there is
a child node, you get
notified, almost
instantaneously.  You can do
whatever you
want s. in this case we're
going to consult a log and write
course, the realtime database is
what we
all know and love.  Firebase
gives you a ton of features,
stat
static testing Cloud based lab,
user op, remote config and,
of course, realtime database.
My favorite          favorite
part you can
pick and choose what you want.
You don't have to use all
of the services.  Of so we're
going to use static hosting,
user auth and realtime database
and use them with the
Google Cloud Platform.
So let's look at our
mock.
>> Yes. It's pretty
clear we're developers and not
designer, I think it's b
eautiful in the way my mother
think
thinks I'm beautiful.  We just
knocked this out in this HTM
HTML.  We have a log in button,
using Firebase you a thent
case, 2016 it log in with
Twitter, it makes it super
easy..
Right below that he    we
can embed a you tube live
stream,
if you've played a video
before, you're familiar with the
D
pad, up, down, left, right,
clicking on the buttons will
send the commands to Firebase.
Of course, what would a
game be without a little trash
talk, so we're going to add
a chat box at the bottom.  Type
your message, hope yfl
something nice, and everyone
else will send it when you
submit.
>> So taking a look at
application a   architecture
right
now.  It's pretty simple.  We
have all cliebt        client
directly
talking to Firebase.  In in
No serve er side mode.  The
comants are
pushed up to Cloud as well as
the chat messages.  Simple is
not crazy and you promise ed
crazy.
>> Maybe a little crazy.
>> We need crazy. This
is not crazy enough for us.
>> That was fun.
>> It was fun.kay. Not
crazy.  Let's do something
crazy.
Let's run the game in one
location, right.  So normally in
connected to Firebase.
It's sending update a, it's
receive willing date a, but it's
responsible for rendering the
game on your Android device,
ISO or desktop web, the client
is responsible for genting
the data and rendering and
handle ing the game logic.  We
wanted to do something
different.  We're going to run
the
game in one location, so all
the commands come, it's render
rendered in one place, and you
can see how everyone is
collaborate ing together.
important to note that we're
also not building a
game, like this session is not
building a game using
Firebase.  The game is just
with a we happen to choose
because we thought it would be
fun and interesting and easy
to follow along.  But you can
imagine just sort of
collaborative environments
where people are sending in
signals disoontly to do edit
data or whatever you have.  It
would be applicable to a wide
variety of platforms.  We're
going to run this in something
called Google Compute Engine
Engine.  It's our virtual
machine offering.  We chose
Windows of our flavor of
virtual machine.
>> The Google Compute E
ngine is pretty cool.  We have
data center        centers
around the world to run VMs.
You have custom
machine type, so wiewr not
locked into 2, 4, 6, 18, you can
pick, 14, 10 CPUs.  Same with
memory.  We're also very
proud of about       billing.
We do subhour bill      billing.
If you have 25
minutes you pay for 25 minute,
we don't round to a hour.
There is no recertificates
instances           instance
rereserve ins or anything like
that, you
Tuesday and get a discount,
which is nice.  My favorite is
how consistently fast they are.
You can spin up 1,000
Linux in like 5 minutes.
Because of the isolation in data
noise y neighbor problem that
you
have in a lot of Clouds.
>> Let's take a look at
how you would create a
virtual machine on Google
Compute Engine.  First you
navigate to u. I      uI.
Click create instance.  This
will bring up
a dialogue with information we
can fill out about the VM.
For example, name, I'll name
mine, mine Windows VM.  Below
that we have different
geographic zones and regions.
So
we've got zones and regions in
Europe, Asia, and the United
States.  I'll choose U.S.  Two
CPUs.  7.5 gigs of RAM and
then choose a operating
operating system.  In
this case Windows serve
server 2012, data center
edition.  Why not. to the power
of sped up video, the machine is
almost instantly create ed.
It's not quite that fast in real
button, you click it, there is a
Chrome browse er that lefts you
remote desktop into your
machine without installing any
software or setting up
configuration.  And look at
that immediately we're in the
virtual machine.  We also have
a SSH in the browse er
functionality for Linux
distributions.
One other thing to point
out about the UI, the link
at the bottom says equivalent
rest.  It's nice to use it to
click around and     and says I
want this OS and this much RAM
and
this much CPU.  If you need to
do that in a repeatable
programmatic manner, if you
have a application spinning up
or down serve ers or a script,
clicking that will give you a
HTTP post request that you can
send to the Google Cloud
platform API and preconfigure
ed with the settings you used
in the UI and same with the G
command line command.
>> So of course, Google
Compute Engine is not the
only place invest to run your
code.  We have something we
like to call the computing
continuum.
>> Continuum.
>> So on the far left we
have, of course,
infrastructure as a service.
Now this is Compute Engine,
raw Linux and Windows VMs, you
can SSH in, you get full
access.  You can run anything
you want.  This is what you
traditionally think about when
you think VMs.  But as you
move up that spectrum, you get
container engine.  Now how
many people here are playing
with docker or docker
containers?  A fair amount.
So a container engine is
how similar mow we run
everything at Google, right,
con     containers.  Instead of
SSH
into the machine and manually
manage it, you get a API for
a cluster and that's a open-
source ed container management
system.  It lets you manage
docker applications on the
cluster.  You can say how many
you want, scale them up, it
will keep them up, things like
that.  You're manage ing
applications in microservices
instead of actually the raw
infrastructure itself.
And as we move up that
spectrum, we get App Engine.
So with App Engine, you just
write your code, upload it and
boom.  We worry about all
that      of that infrastructure
stuff.
Scale it for you, security
patch ch   es, make sure it's up
and
returning.  It lets you focus
on application logic and
building a great app without
worrying about the operation
stuff underneath.  Finally we
have Cloud functions which
are currently in alpha.  So
these are with a we like to
call event-driven program
models.  Something happens in
the
Cloud and it triggers a
function to run, against serve
erless
computing.  Something in
Firebase triggers a function or
likepubsub, Cloud storage, what
have you.  It can trigger
little functions to run and do
something without you worry
worrying about the
infrastructure.
>> So now that we've got
the code running on the
serve er, how do we connect to
Firebase?  You're probably
familiar with the Firebase
client SDK for Android, IOS and
web.  If you use the technology
stack as Java or Java
script on the serve er you can
use the same SDK to connect to
Firebase.  If off text stack or
language not one of those,
we have third party, Python, PH
P, riewber pearl
Ru, about y, go, and C
sharp.  They're third party,
not supported by Google
officially so your mileage may
vary, but I encourage
enencourage you
to check it out.  If you have a
text stack not represented,
Firebase is a rest API.  If you
can make a REST request
post you can use to access
Firebase functionality, which is
awesome.
>> In our case we're
going to be using Node.js and
iewtioning robot JS it's pretty
cool, let's you take
Node.js and translate to
keyboard commands.  In this case
we're going to connect to
Firebase, use the same
connection
we used on the client, and go
to the command subtree.
Every time we get a up, down,
left, or right, all we're
going to do is send a keyboard
command to our game.  Our
game can be any game off the
shelf.  We're just going to
send the keyboard commands.
It's already Firebase enable ed.
Pretty cool.
>> And we're going ing
to livestream everything to You
Youtube.  It gives us the
ability to encode the desktop.
The entire desktop whatever is
happening on it, we can live
stream to You Tube.  As a bonus
we can embed it in our game
game.  As you play it and see
the character respond to your
commands, you see it respond to
everyone elses command,
they're all watching the same
YouTube stream.  As a bonus
free platform, you don't pay
for ingress or egress charges
which is really nice.
>> If we take a look at
the architecture, we have the
client, again, speaking
directly to Firebase, pushing up
the chat and the command
message, and then we have our
Node.js process running on
Windows VM and it's going to be
taking the commands and relayi
ng it to the game, right.
Then we're going to take the
whole screen and encode it and
send it up to YouTube live.
Pretty cool.
>> Cool.
>> But cool is not crazy.
>> Pretty crazy, huge
multiplayer, same tain
simultaneous game.
>> Not crazy enough.
>> Let me think. You
know what I always thought,
type ing is boring, what if we
get rid of keyboard and
buttons.  What if you could
control this game with the
power of your mind?
>> Wait. Wait. What?
>> Just kidding, we don't
have a mind-reading API.
But we're the next best thing,
Cloud cap     Speech API.
You've
probably seen similar
technology, as you talk it's
transcribe ing your spoken word
into text.  We talked a lot
yesterday during the key
keynote about Google assist.
This is
the same spech-to-text
technology that powers all of
that
at Google using machine
learning.  It's just an API
request
in HTTP post request, so it
needs technology stack, serve
er,
client, browse er, what have
you, it can take advantage of
Cloud speech API.
So like Bret said, it's a
simple post request, in
this case we're going o it 64
encode the audio and then
send it up.  That's pretty much
all you have to do.  And
you get back the transcript.
And in this case how old is
the Brooklyn bridge, 98%
confident.
>> Are you asking me how
would?
>> Am I asking you? I
don't know.
>> It's 146 years old.
>> Thank you. I did not
need to know that.
>> So it's looking a lot
better.  We didn't magically
become designers but we took
advantage of material design
to kind of relay out and
reorganize our app.  Colors look
better, the design looks
better.  You'll notice there is
no
D pad at all, there is no way
to control this, except by
clicking that button and speaki
ng the command.  So instead
of pressing up and down and
left and right, you actually
say aloud, up, down, left,
right, and the game will respond
and send those commands up
through Firebase.
So looking at your
architecture, we again don't use
speech API, the clients talk
directly to the Cloud Speech
API, get the transcript, send
it up to Firebase, and then
again, our Node.js application
running on Windows is going to
relay the commands to the
game and then live stream e
verything to    to YouTube.
>> But. Come on, that's
a little bit more craze he
ee, like voice.
>> You can't be satisfy.
So how do we make this even
more crazy ier?  What if, what
if our game got so popular it
was played around the world?
>> What. What do you
mean what if?
>> I'm sorry. Yes. When
our game gets so popular,
it is played around the world.
Well not everyone speaks
English.  So let's introduce a
multilingual support for our
app.  It will be awesome if I
could verbally speak in my
native tongue and it would
instantly be translate ed into
the
native tongue of everyone else
who is playing this game in
realtime.  And conversely as
they spoke in their native
tongue, it would show up on my
screen in my language.  I
think that's pretty crazy.
So for that we use the
Google translate API.  You
probably used the Google
translate app or been to
translate
translate.google on the web you
can type text and translate
to English and paste in French
and trans light to Jap
translate to
Japanese.
Super
Super seize ee.  Now it's
available on the Google Cloud
API
to use your same machine
technology in your application.
>> Again a simple HTTP
request, is he end up the
string and target language,
which is espanol and we get
back the translate ed text and
we automatically detect the
source language for you, which
is really nice.
>> Awesome.
>> So we have a lot more
machine-learning APIs.  One
I like to talk about is the
Cloud Vision API.  You get the
same power that Google photos
have, you send sup a photo
and you get very detailed
information like emotion
detection, object detection, OC
R, all these kind of cool
stuff, again, with a simple
REST API call.  If you're using
tense letter flow today, you
can use Cloud machine learning
on our clusters so get the purr
of CPU, GP Us and TP Us
that we have in Google Cloud to
train your machine learning
models.
Believe me when I say
there is more coming soon.
>> Sounds excite ing.
Here is our architecture as it
stands now.  Again, we've got
client, tab lets, desktop,
mobile, they are transcribe ing
your spoken word, and then
translate ing it, if necessary,
using the translate API, sync
using Firebase, both to our
serve er, which is running
Node.js but also potentially
every
other client logged in using
Firebase.  It's live streamed
everything to YouTube to people
around the world can watch.
Why don't we do a little demo
and show you the game we
built so you can see the APIs
in action.
I'm going to be playing
on my desktop and Sandeep
will play on his phone.  First
I'll demonstrate the chat
portion.  So let's see.  Hello
and welcome to Google I/O.
And look at that, almost
instantaneously on the screen
you
can see hello and welcome to
Google I/O.  Almost as soon as
I finished talking.  Let's see
how it syncs through
Firebase.  Sandeep if you want
to reply.
>> SANDEEP DINESH:
Everyone here is so cool.
>> BRET McGOWEN: You're
just pandering now.  You
see almost instantaneously it
showed up on the chat box.
Everyone here is so cool.  Now
let's try a different
language, let me switch from
English down to espa in, ol
and            nol and
almost instantaneously it
translates to Spanish and I see
it in the original.  I'm not
that great at Spanish so let
me switch back to English.
>> SANDEEP DINESH:
Wait.  I took span i
Spanish in high
school.
>> BRET McGOWEN: You're
the expert.
>> SANDEEP DINESH: Oh,
yeah.
>> BRET McGOWEN: (the
speaking Spanish).
>> SANDEEP DINESH: And
the classic spannic 10
span      Spanish 101
phrase in realtime Bret you
want to play the game.
>> SANDEEP DINESH:
Let's play.  This is my windows
remote desktop on the left.
I'll click start and then
explain the game.  The point of
the game is to get the red
dot in the bottom left corner
to the finish line, which is
the blue dot in the top right
corner.  We're going to do
this by verbally issue ing
commands to the game
simultaneous
simultaneously to control the
character.  We have 5 minutes
in which to do that.  So let's
give it a whirl.
>> BRET McGOWEN: Let's
do it.
>> SANDEEP DINESH: Up,
right. right.  Right.
up Bret up.
>> SANDEEP DINESH: Up.
>> BRET McGOWEN: Up.
>> BRET McGOWEN: Right,
up, up.
>> SANDEEP DINESH:
There we go.  Up, up,.
>> BRET McGOWEN: Up,
left, left.
>> SANDEEP DINESH:
Left?  What are you doing?
>> BRET McGOWEN: I
don't know.  Up.
>> SANDEEP DINESH:
Right, right, right.
>> BRET McGOWEN: Up?
Oh, my God we suck at this.
>> SANDEEP DINESH: We
are really not good at this
game.  That's all right.  I
think that was fun.
(Applause).
>> But, you
know, fun is not crazy.
>> Oh, no.
>> Yeah.
>> I don't like where
this is headed.
>> You like it it. We're
going to make it crazy.
Ladies and gentlemen, get out
your phone and play, this
includes you on the livestream.
It's going to ask for geo
geolocation, hit qle, I'll get
into why later, of course if
you're not comfortable, hit no.
Get out your phone, come
on, all get it out, we're going
to make it loud in here.
This is not going to work, but
it's going to be fun.
>> This is definitely
going to be crazy.  All right.
>> So we're going to
restart the game and give the
whole world 5 minutes to get
Mr. red dot to Mrs. blue dot.
5 minutes.
>> All right.
>> All right. We're
going to give everyone a few
seconds
seconds.
>> Raise your hand if
anyone at all is on.
>> You might have notice
ed the UI looks a little
different.  We have a hold to
speak button.  You press it
down, you speak, are let it go,
it will transcribe your
text.  Some devices don't allow
browse er support for the
microphone.  So we have a Dpad,
but yeah.  We can't build a
native app in time and push it
into the app store, I know.
So unfortunately, PR said, no
live chat.  Blame PR.
>> It was because I was
swearing a lot in rehearsal
and they thought, you know.
>> They didn't trust us.
All right.  So I think most
people are ready to go.  We're
going to give everyone 5
minutes.  3, 2,
1 -- what is this!.
>> Oh, my God!
>> Wow!
>> This is amazing!
>> (Laughing)
.
>> No. Come on you're so
close! love it.  There is
trolls in every crowd
(Laughing).
>> Who is trolling with
left?  Come an!
>> It's beautiful.
>> You saw 4 minutes.
This is chaos.  All right.
Come on, you can do it!
>> We're never going to
get out of this little -- oh,
oh --
(audience members
shouting).
>> So many people hitting
left, this is amazing!
>> It is.
>> Oh, we got out!.
>> Remember to hold down
and let go.
audience members shouting).
>> Oh, so close!
>> This is intense.
>> Oh, my God! Oh, oh,
oh, !
>> Almost!
>> Oh, ! Oh, !
>> Wait. It's in the
corner!
>> How did that even
happen?
>> So close!
>> Oh, it's right there.
It's right there!
>> Oh, my God! Oh, !
Our VM is overwhelmed, we should
>> I know. Right. This
is amazing.
>> I don't even know
what's going on.  I am like
lost
lost.
>> Any tips for them?
>> Okay. Everyone stop
except one person, how about
that (Laughing).
>> That will never work.
Oh, we're so far down now.
>> Oh, my God. This is
crazy.  I don't even know
what's going on.
>> Who else is using the
speech API?  Who got it
acetowork?  I               to
work?
>> I think it overwhelmed
the WiFi.  So I wrote this
game in Adobe Flash.  Let's
blank it.  That was ridiculous
ridiculously crazy.  Round of
aplawses for              a.
(Applause)
applause for
everyone.  That
was crazy.  That was crazy.
>> That was amazing.
>> But, come on, one more
thing, just for me, old
time sake?
>> Just a little bit.
>> A little bit more
crazy?
>> A little bit. Okay.
So we'll do something a
little bit more crazy.  We're
going to talk about big data.
At Google we love big data,
it's in our DNA, we've been
doing it since day 1.  We have
a ton of tools to let you in
had interact with, pro serks
and analyze big data.  I'm
going to talk about big query.
So big query is our data
analytica warehouse tool.  What
does that mean?  It means
you can upload, gigabyte, tare
a bytes into it, and using the
same scwel, the same sql you
already know.  It's a manage ed
service you don't have to worry
about scale ing
infrastructure or replicate ing
the data or worry about
back
backups or worry about how much
ram              how much RAM
or CPU, you just upload
the data and as soon as it is
uploaded we can query.  Query
Queries that used to take hours
and days      days can now be
done
literally in seconds.
>> Pretty cool. So
again, thank you, guys, for that
meta      metadata, that geo
location.  We basically
collected from the client.  We
used Google maps to get some geo
coding to get your city and
state.  And browse er
type and device type.  Simple
metadata, in your application
temperature sensors coming
in, or how many people clicked
the red button versus green.
Things like that.  So thank
you, guys, for enable ing that.
ll right.  So here is the code,
how we got it
into Big inquiry.  It's pretty
straightforward.  First we
required the G Cloud client
library.  It is a client
library that wraps a lot of
Google Cloud Platform functions
in a nice sort of node-friendly
style.  We've got these
available for Ruby, Python,
Java and Go.  Rather than
making the HTTP requests
yourself you can use the library
in a manner familiar to you in
those languages.e we require G
Cloud we're going to reference B
ig
query and then dataset name.
The dataset name is just the
database name, essentially.
Then we'll reference the table
specifically.  So we have this
child added listener, this
is the same child added listen
listener we see early
ier.  This is
the app running on the windows
VM.  It's getting node fied
through child added.  It's
going to rely the keystrokes
into the game as you saw
and     after that it will be a
table
insert into Big query.  It's
going to use snapshot.  This
is the JSON payload.  This is
the payload that has the
command, and then, for example,
city and state of where you
executed the command.
>> We had to
transform
Didn't have to transform
the Firebase data at all.
>> Useful. Then after
that you you can do post-
post-processing you want.
>> Once it's in had Big
query it looks like any
database.  You have columns and
rows and you can write some
SQL.  We have an API so you can
programmatically interact
with it as well.
>> All right. Speaking
of interaking,
interacting let's take a
look at the data we just
inserted.  As you were playing
we
were but the         putting
the data into company cap big
query.  It's
live data.  So I'm going to do
a select star, I know it's
bad form but less type ing on
stage, then let's see, let's do
orld
order by timestamp descending.
And then let's run that.
See what kind of data we get.
All right.  So we see --
okay.  So we've got a lot in
mountainview, but then also in
California and Utah.  Good
job Utah playing along.
Awesome.  And then again, it's
just SQL.  So let's see what
were the most common commands
that people issue ed?  So I'm
just going to do a count.
>> Okay. If left wins
I'm lost faith in humanity
right now.
>> There is a troll in
every crowd.  I'm just going
to group by command, run that.
And you can see that, wow,
wow -- (Laughing).
You see number one was
right and number two is up.
It makes sense in had the
context of the game.  We're
start
starting in the bottom left
corner of the game and trying
to get to the top right.  So
most commands would either be
right or up.
>> Trolls Trolls, of
course, down and left.  Come
on, guys.
>> Who was on team left,
come on.  Yeah.  This guy
here (Laughing).  All right.  I
have a couple of other save
saved query ies so we can take
a look at that data.  Again,
snags you ingest the data into
Big query it is immediately
available to query.  Let's see
what kind of devices were
people using?  Let's see.  Run
this.  Another query -- oops
oops. we go.
>> Okay. Most people
were on the phone.  We have
about 1, 200 clicks from a
desktop and a few people on a
tablet.  That's pretty cool.
tablets.
>> Go tablet, team tabl
et?
>> I don't have a tab
let.
>> Let's see by city.
I'm just going to do --
another group by city and see
where we got. -- wow!  Look at
at the city, let's go through
them.  Hit next.
>> Yeah.
>> Look at at the city
ies.
>> Seattle.
>> Thanks to everyone on
the livestream for playing
around, by the way.  That's
awesome.  We got a really good
international audience.  That's
awesome.
>> You can see that data
came in live, right.  We
couldn't make this up if we
tried.  We probably could
though, but we didn't
(Laughing).  But yeah.  Wow!
Shout
out to all the guys on the live
stream.  Thank you so much.
(Applause).
And of
course, everyone here as well.
(Applause).
>> So one
thing I want to point out, you
might be
look will go at the query and
it says 179 seconds elapse ed,
you might be thinking for a few
hundred or a few thousand
rows it's not that fast.
You're right.  Big query is not
designed to be super performant
over small data set, it's
designed to be super fast over
huge datasets on the giga
gigabyte scale.  Don't use it
as a SQL date      database but
if you
want to dump a lot of data into
it and query it.  Like log,
like web logs, you can query
massive amounts of data in a
few seconds.  In fact, where it
product came from at Google
we needed to analyze all of our
ads data, as you imagine, data
and Ads log data is humongous,
it was taking hours
and houring to run simple
query.  We developed the
technology that became Big
query.
>> You can query tera
bytes in seconds.
>> Literally in seconds.
>> Imagine this game, we
played for two seconds and
generate ed all that data.  If
this game was running 24 hours
a day, 7 days a week, you can
imagine how much data we're
going to be generate ing,
right.  A normal database is
going
to be overwhelmed by that
amount of data.  Big query is
definitely whether
where you want to store this
type of data. course that's not
the only big data we have at
Google.  We have Cloud -- you
can get a fully bootstrapped
includes der in 90 seconds.  If
you're running Spark or HAD
HADUP and want to move to the
Cloud this is exactly built
for you.  Then we have Cloud
data flow, this is the next
generation of map, with one API
you can do batch, streaming
and ETL.  We have open sources
is as Apache bean and when
you run on the Cloud, we do all
the operations for you, the
autoscale ing, instance, things
like that.  Which is really
nice.
And for all the data a
nalysts out there, we have
Cloud data lab, it lets you do
exploration and visual
analysis with open-source note
wook          notebooks and died
directly into
machine leern
direct
tied directly into
machine learning and big data
tools.
>> Here is the final..
You have browse er, tablet,
desktops, mobile, listening to
verbal speech, using the
Cloud speech API, translate ing
back and forth from multiple
languages
languages if necessary, syncing
everything in realtime
through Firebase to every other
client and to our serve er,
be which is running our game
and node app.  Live streaming
everything to YouTube and
inserting into Big query where
it
is immediately available for
you to query and see what your
users are up to.
>> You know what is
really crazy?
>> What?
>> You know what?
>> The whole thing.
>> We built the whole
thing in a week.  That was
really crazy.  Shows
Showses the power of Firebase
and Google
Cloud and how it makes building
applications a little by
the easy ier.  Check out
Firebase at new home at
Firebase.
Firebase.google.com and we also
have two really cool You
Youtube chants the Google
developers channel?  How many
have subscribe ed
subscribe ed already?  Awesome.
And the Google platform
channel, we have a ton of Cloud
content coming out all the
time.  If you're interested in
learning more about Cloud,
we have a lot for you to inter
act with here at I/O.
Tomorrow our colleague is doing
a session on big data, so
he is already over here in the
corner.  If you are at all
interested in big data, we just
hit, just the very tip of
the iceberg of big data
offerings in Google Cloud, check
it
out.  He's going to talk a lot
about the big data offerings
over the intellects 2016
datasets.
>> That sounds scary.
>> No way I'm touching
that.  So that is in stage 5
tomorrow at 11:00 be sure to
check it out.  Please stop by
the code lab, we have a bunch
of code labs for you to get
your hands on Google Cloud
Platform, interact, write sample
being playing.
>> Are we getting played
off the stage?  (Laughing).
So if you go to the code lab,
any machine you see, hop on,
we have the Cloud code lab, a
sandbox right out here to the
left spx Firebase             .
>> Firebase and Google
Cloud are next to each other.
>> We have a emotion
detector, can you make ee
emotions
and it colors your photo
depending on emotion.  And then
finally tomorrow at 9:00 a.m.
we have office hours at the
office hours tent, so we'd love
to hear what your questions
are about Cloud, what you're
doing with Cloud now, and then
any sort of interesting
projects you might have for us
to
talk about and see what we can
do.
(Applause).
>> Thank
you.
>> Thank you all so much.
>> What's up? question.
music playing)
much for coming.  If we could
ask everyone to take their seats
.  We are about to
get ready.  So have a seat.
Last call.  If everyone would
please take their seats.  Thank
you so much for coming.  We're
super excited tonight.  We hope
you guys are, too.  I think
congrats, you guys are all
nominees, .  This should be
should be a really fun
show.  Quick heads up, when we
announce the winners, nobody
knows if they've won, so when we
announce the winners tonight,
please approach the stage using
the stairs over here.  Come on
up and receive your award.  I'll
give you a warning.  It says
quite heavy, so get ready.
You won't have to speak.  Do
your thing.  There will be
There will be a
photographer taking pictures.
Feel free to just exit back on
the side of the stage again.
Once you exit, we'll have a host
over here, and she can take
your award.  Take it to the back
and then after the ceremony
we'll connect with you guys, so
if you want to take it with you,
or if you want us to ship it
back to you, we can just connect
afterwards
:  Any questions
?
>> Anybody using this
microphone, if you could keep it
in this position, and you could
project a little bit, because
we are told there might be quite
some extraneous noise outside.
It would just help with the
volume level.  Thanks very much
:
Awards
.
>> .
>>
>> 7:00
#
7:00
>>
Please take
your seats.  The program will
begin shortly.
2016 Google play
awards
.
Please welcome Purnima Kochikar,
head of apps and games BD,
Google play    Play.
>> PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Good
evening.  How's everyone doing?
(Applause)
>> PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Welcome to
the first ever Google play
awards
.  Since we announced this
program about a couple weeks ago
, there has been incredible
excitement from the developer
community and the press from all
around the world.  This would
not be possible without you and
your work.  So give yourself a
big round of applause.
(Applause)
accomplished together since we
launched Google play,
Play           Google Play, it's
pretty amazing.  And the
momentum isn't       isn't
letting up.  Your apps and games
now reach a billion users every
month through play app,
and               play car
Play, and they're driving 50
billion downloads in 2016 alone
.  Pretty amazing, isn't
isn't it?
(Applause)
Each day my team and I have the
privilege of working with you to
help you build successful
mobile businesses and each day
you use the platforms and tools
we provide to create apps and
games that amaze and inspire us.
Tonight we take the time to
celebrate you and the great work
you have done over the last
year.  Tonight we honor ten
examples of outstanding
achievement
.
(Applause)
So let's get the show started,
shall we?  All right.
(Laughter)
welcome Bob Meese, head of games
BD, Google Play
.
(Applause) Bobs
(Applause)
>> Bob Meese OB MEESE:
Hi, everyone.  What a great
crowd.  This is a lot of fun.
Indies provide fun, deep,
meaningful experiences, spanning
games of all genre.  They prove
that developers of any size can
succeed on Android.  I judged
the first Google Play Ind
ie festival last month.  We're
thrilled to support this
community and it's so important
to us.  We have the Indie corner
, which is a dedicated
collection of indie games we
support.  Look at the nominee.
>> Stand out indie nominee are
Alpha Bear
, Alto's    to's adventure
Adventure, fast    Fast
like    Like a fox
Fox, Kink
o.
Stand
Are you ready?
Alpha Bear.
(Applause)
>> Best use of Google Play game
services
.
>> For the next award,
increase competition on Google
Play that help create a great
community of gamers, with
features like multiplayer and
leader boards, they help keep
gamers engaged and keep them
coming back for more.  All the
nominees in this category
integrated multiple Google Play
game features that enhanced the
overall user experience.
Let's take a look at the
nominees.
>> Best use of Google Play games
services nominee are sea   Sea
battle
Battle 2, table     Table
tennis      Tennis touch
Touch
,
cat adventures              Cat
Adventures              Cat
Adventures, power     tower
matted        madness
Tower Madness             T
ower Madness 2.
So
many
Tower Madness 2.
Zombie Highway 2  .
Best use of Google Play game
services.
>> All right. For the next one,
what are               one, can
we have an applause for the
nominees?  All right.  Cool.
(Applause)
And the winner is:  Table tennis
Tennis touch
Touch.
(Applause)
Please welcome Larissa Fontaine
, head of apps BD, Google Play.
(Applause)
>> LARISSA FONTAINE: So having
recently finished a home
improvement project, I used even
more new apps than I usually
do, which is kind of a lot.  It
was incredible with the adoption
of material design how quickly
I was able to navigate and find
recommendations and ideas in
well-designed apps.  They were
enjoyable, intuitive, and helped
me find exactly what I was
looking for without having to
hunt and peck.  It's not just
home improvement apps.  Over one
million apps have adopted
material design elements in just
the last two years since we
announced them.  This year's  's
nominees represent first class
material design implementations
across many categories.  And the
nominees are.
>> Best use of material design
nominees are
:  Bring, fab awe us
, fab you         , fabulous
Fabulous,
Robinhood,
to Do list, Viv
Vivo.  Best use of material
design
.
>> LARISSA FONTAINE: And the
winner is:  Robinhood
.
(Applause)
>> Standout
start-up
.
(Laughter)
I'm still here.  Similar to our
focus on indie, this year we are
putting start-up developers
front and center.  As we talked
about a couple times over the
last two days, we have launched
an early access program for apps
that are still in beta to
connect developers with a
community of early adopters to
get great feedback early in your
development.
We are consistently amazed with
the incredible funnel of fresh
and unique experiences coming
from lean teams, and this group
of nominees represent incredible
startups from across the
ecosystem.  And the nominees are
>> Standout start-up, nominees
are:
DubSmash, Hopper
, musically         Musically
Robinhood
, Robinhood, .
And the winner is:  Hopper.
(Applause)
.
(Music)
welcome bench Galbraith
Ben gal     Galbraith,
developer of product group.
(Applause)
>> BEN GALBRAITH: Last may we
opened a dedicated
category based on age and
popular characters.  As the
father of eight young children,
all one wife, all one at a time,
this section is enormously
popular in our household.  We
love these apps.  Let's take a
look at the nominees.
>> Best families app nominee as
are:  Card wars    Wars,
adventure         Adventure time
Time, Lego Jur     o
Jurassic          o Jurassic
world     World, my  My very
Very hungry      Hungry c
Cater       Caterpillar  ar,
Thinkrolls
2, Tok
a Natur       a Nature.  Best
families app.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: And the win
ner is:  Thinkrolls
2.
(Applause)
>> Most innovative
.  Sgloebz
>> BEN GALBRAITH: The most
innovative category highlights
the apps and games that bring
the wow moments that demonstrate
something truly new and unique.
This can come in the form of
new controls for a game based on
the latest sensors, or it could
be             it could be deep
personalization that gives you
an intimate, emotional
connection to the experience.
In whatever form it comes,
innovation can transform
something ordinary into
something immer       immersiv
immersive, all in the
babel device that
in the
mobile device that fits in the
palm of your hand.
>> Most innovative nominees are:
Fabulou
ous, Fast space       like
Like a fox
Fox, New York Times VR, smart
Smart news
News, this    This war   War
of mine    Mine
, .
Most innovative.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: The winner is
New York Times VR.
(Applause)
welcome Sameer Samat, VP product
management
Google Play.
(Applause)  realizing now that
many of you did not get the memo
on the appropriate dress code
for this evening's  's attire.
You're forgiven, however.
(Laughter)
Tiptoed look my best
honor of some of the great he
have        est developers in
the world.
(Applause)
One of the favorite parts of my
job is watching developers take
a new design or an ancient
technology and take experiences
that are truly changing people's
lives.  The apps and the games
that they create offer a service
, piece of functionality, or an
entirely new experience that is
truly inspiring and amazing.
Being an early adopter is really
hard.  It means challenging the
status quo.  It means pushing
your team in different
directions.  These are all
things that we at Google truly
admire in this year's  's
nominees.  Let's take a look.
>> Early adopter nominees are:
Glide
, mechanic        Mechanic
estate      Estate
, Minecr        Minecraft story
Story mode    Mode,
world     World around
Around me  Me
, Thu
umper.
Early adopter
.
>> SAMEER SAMAT: And the winner
this year in the early adopter
category is world     World
around      Around me  Me
Zumper.
Early adopter.
>> SAMEER SAMAT: And the winner
this year in the early adopter
category is World Around Me.
(Applause)
>> Go global.
>> SAMEER SAMAT: Given how
popular Android devices are
around the world, we often get
asked by developers, how do I
make a successful entry into a
new market?  Many people think
that localizing an app means
taking an app from one
from one language to another,
but it's so much more than that.
For an app to feel truly
successful in a different
country, users there need to
believe that it was built for
them.  This is all about colors
and character chases
choices and contextual relevance
as well as language.  It's
really hard to do       to do.
And so this year we wanted to
honor a set of developers that
exemplify what great
localization looks like.  The
nominees are.
>> Go global nominees are:
Dragon
Doken battle
Battle
,
Dragon Doken Battle music
Music smash
, Pokemon shuffle       Shuffle
mobile      Mobile, Fr
Freeletic           Freeletics
body    Body weight, go
global.
>> SAMEER SAMAT: And the winner
in the go global category,
Pokemon Shuffle mobile
Mobile
.
(Music)
(Applause)
Jaimie Rosenberg,
VP Google Play.
(Applause)
>> JAIMIE ROSENBERG: Hi,
everyone.  It's incredibly
humbling just looking out at
this room.  It's incredibly
humbling as a reminder to see
how far our Android developer
community has come since we
first launched the platform back
in 2008.  We're now at the
final two award categories of
the night, best app, and best
game.  The nominees in these
categories are true examples of
the amazing work being done by
all of you and our Android
developers all over the world.
the award for best app.
Whether you're looking for a
recipe, ideas for a home remodel
, or ways to stay informed or
entertained, the nominees
managed         in this category
make your day more productive
and more fun.  They serve their
users in different ways, but
what they all have in common is
great design, intuitive user
experience, and broad appeal.
Let's take a look at the
nominees for best app.
>> Best app nominees are
:  Houzz
, tune    Tune In radio
Radio, Buzz      BuzzFeed
BuzzFeed, Col
Color       Colorfy
.
>> SAMEER SAMAT: And the winner
for the best app is:  Houzz
.
(Applause).  Congrats
(Applause)
Congrats, guys.  Well done
.
>> Best game.
(Applause)
to try that one at home later.
(Laughter)
This year's  's nominees for
best game gave everyone a reason
to be a gamer, from big screen
characters to small screen heros
, from puzzles to clans to
battles, these nominees connect
and delight users everywhere.
They're also a ton of fun.  They
also tend to showcase the very
best of what an droid device can
do.  So let's take a look at
the nominees for bifida game
>> Best
for best game
>> Best game nominees are:
Alpha Bear
, clash     Clash of kings
Kings, clash
clash       clash
Clash Royale, marvel
Marvel future      Future fight
Fight, Star Wars, galaxy
Galaxy of heros     Heros.
Best game.
>> JAIMIE ROSENBERG: And the
winner of the Google Play award
for best game is:  Clash
Royale
.
(Applause)
stage Purnima Kochikar.
One more huge round of
applause for all the nominees
and the winners, please.
(Applause)
Make some noise!
With so many amazing apps and
games, it was an extremely
difficult task for the panel to
pick the nominees and the
winners.  Thank you for
constantly pushing the
boundaries to show us what's
what's possible.  I hope
you had a good time tonight
.  And I hope you're energized
to go out and use the new tools
and features that we announced
all through I/O to create new
apps and games.
(Applause)
waiting to see what you will
create next.  We are constantly
amazed and it's what makes our
jobs fun every day.  But first,
it's time to go out and have
some fun.  Please join us for
after hours happening all around
the venue.  Good night, and